von
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, was probieren wir aus? Also, ich würde fast sagen, okay, das ist die beliebteste
wie es aussieht. Gold. Trance Knight. Was ist hier los? Wollen die hier irgendwelche
Minderheiten hier? Was ist hier los? Anzeige ist raus. Toss. Kann das Trance Knight heißen
einfach so. Gleich Abmahnung losschicken. Gleich Berechtigungsbeauftragter ist informiert.
So, also entweder nehmen wir das da. Xfce Trance Knight. Okay, wir nehmen das. Das scheint
ja mehr oder weniger so. Hab ich das nicht letzten sogar schon runtergeladen? Hab ich
das nicht? Kannst du irgendwie nicht so ganz entscheiden. Doch, ich hab schon runtergeladen,
oder? Ach nee! Das ist ein bisschen aktueller. Okay, dann warten wir ein bisschen runtergeladen
und löschen das alte. Schade ja nichts. Ein bisschen Platz machen. Da kann ich bei
der Gelegenheit nämlich auch einfach mal ein paar alte VMs. Ja, und danach probieren
wir auf jeden Fall mal einen von den... Ach, da hab ich es runtergeladen. Nee, danach probiere
ich auf jeden Fall mal eins von den Tiling-Window-Managers aus. Das wird aber ein bisschen abgedrehter.
Ich wette mit euch, ich kann das nicht bedienen. Weil ich hab weder BSM-WM noch Herbstluft-WM.
Ich vermute mal, das ist Herbstluft-WM. Der Name schon alter. Herbstluft-WM. Wer hat sich
das denn ausgedacht? Das klingt überhaupt nicht Stonks-mäßig genug. Das muss heute
Hyper-Experience-Window-Manager heißen oder so. Dann ist das gut. Die brauchen mal alle,
die paar sind Stonks-Leute, die ihnen ein paar Namen empfehlen. Du checkst gar, es gibt
noch gar nichts zu checken. Unterm Strich, wir laden uns eine aktuelle Linux-Distribution
runter, die jetzt erst rausgekommen ist vor einer Weile und gucken uns mal an, ob man
damit klarkommt. Das ist so, da sind uns weg der ganze Sache. Blockchain-WM. Oh, das ist
auch gut. Blockchain-WM. Was passiert denn bei Blockchain-WM? Jeder Klick löst irgendeine
anonyme Bitcoin, wobei Bitcoin-Transaktionen sind ja nicht so wirklich anonyme. Was ist
denn das für Farbenblinde? Moment, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Man kann eine Krankheit haben,
dass man das besser lesen kann als das. Geht das? Ich mein, das sieht einfach nur total
unförmig aus. Yep, okay. Ah, Moment, das hat nichts mit Farbenblindheit zu tun. Das
ist für Leute, die Probleme haben, Wörter richtig zuzuordnen und sowas. Ah, Big Brain
Chat, siehste? Der Chat, der Chat muss mir wieder mal alles erklären. Big Brain Chat
und das ganz ohne Prime-Subs heute schon. Aber komm, gibt's ja heute. Also der IQ muss
weiter steigen. Gar nicht überfüllt mein Desktop mit der Absicht. Ich weiß, ich lass
den auch so, weil ich weiß, dass der Chat meinen Desktop mag. Übrigens, der Desktop
ist schon so voll. Ich weiß nicht, ob es euch auffällt, aber wenn ich hier die Maus
drüber bewege, seht ihr, hier ist alles flüssig und hier lag das. Erkennt man das? Das laggt
voll dieses Markieren. Ich mein, was haben die sich bei Microsoft gedacht? Warum kann
ich nicht 150 Desktop-Symbole lag-frei markieren? Was soll das? He doesn't know. Ja, das stimmt.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht? Was ist das? Warum hab ich ein Netzlaufwerk, was 0wgrösser
Kekweh heißt? Ich will jetzt nicht raufklicken, weil ich mir nicht so ganz sicher bin, wo
man da rauskommt. Spielst du auch POE? Denkst du, äh, die Season hab ich nicht gespielt,
nee. Und die haben ja auch die nächste Season auf irgendwie Mitte Januar oder so verschoben.
Sofern juckt mich gerade, also, ja, egal. Kannst du mal Room Tour machen von einem Schreibtisch?
Ja, ich will ja insgesamt mal Haustour machen, weil ja viele auch schon gefragt haben, wie
das mit Heimautomatisierung aussieht und wie es jetzt nach der Baustelle aussieht und sonst
was. Aber da muss ich halt gucken, dass ich nicht zu viel reveal. So, okay, True Nost können
wir wegschmeißen, das gibt's gar nicht mehr. Das haben wir mal ausprobiert, aber jetzt
ist Fad. Oh. What the fuck. Appears to be in use? What the fuck? Moment, wo liegt die angeblich?
Open VM Directory. Documents, Virtual Machines. Was? Tatsächlich? Null. Und warum hab ich die,
vor allem warum hab ich die auf C und nicht sonstwo? Hier haben wir irgendwie alles Ubuntu
rumfliegen. Das muss ich mal alles wegschmeißen, das verbraucht unnötig Festplattenplatz.
Das kommt jetzt alles weg. Das ist bestimmt auch in use. Hä? Was hat's denn für Schmerzen?
Darf ich nicht löschen. Na gut. Darf ich das wenigstens löschen? E-Doppelpunkt-VMs,
wobei das könnten wir einfach verwenden. Das verwenden wir jetzt einfach. Das verwenden
wir, was haben wir denn? 4G RAM? 4 CPU, 4 CPU Kerne. Okay, weil wir 4 CPU Kerne haben,
dann können wir auch YOLO Style machen. Einfach mal 8GB RAM. Bloß dass das jetzt Rename
Heftorts ist. Oh, es gibt Subs. Ich hab's gerade gesehen. Henry2777, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Massive IQ++ für den Chat. Take Ownership klappt bei mir immer nicht.
Doch, ich zeig's dir. Ich hab die E-Meldung auch öfters und die geht bei mir nie. Da
sagt der Lawne, die VM gibt's nicht, was aber Blödsinn ist. Wenn ich neu starte, dann geht
alles. Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat. Ja, Henry, danke für den Sub. Hab ich
dazu irgendwas übersehen? Hast du das Video-Reihe von Microsoft Engineer gesehen, der den Windows
Taskmanager gecode hat? Nee, ich dachte, das ist extrem langweilig. So, weil der Taskmanager,
was könnte an Windows uninteressanter sein als der Taskmanager? Wobei es durchaus sein
kann, dass es doch spannend ist, aber ich fand halt, es sah nicht spannend aus. Chat,
seid ihr überhaupt schon jetzt endlich eingehackt hier auf die IP? Also ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
gedacht, der Chat braucht nicht so lange dafür. Wie gesagt, POE hab ich diese Saison nicht
gespielt. So, jetzt hab ich Chat durchgescrollt. Heft or Hype? Echt? Ich kenn das nicht. Das
soll angeblich eine der Distros sein, die gut aussehen, was ja meistens darauf raus
läuft, dass der alleroberste Layer hübsch gemacht ist und der Rest halt nicht richtig
funktioniert. Zumindest war das bisher meine Erfahrung mit so Polish-Distros. Deep in mal
außen vor. Deep in, auch wenn es der China-Linux ist, macht tatsächlich einen ganz guten Eindruck.
So, Heftor, da sind wir. Ist der Download fertig? Jawoll. Bam, Heftor XFCE. Auf geht's. Oh,
Moment, hab ich jetzt gerade ein TrueNAS dran gehängt? Nee, ne, hab ich nicht. Wann kommt
denn eigentlich das nächste Windows-Update? Ist das jetzt nicht irgendwann soweit? Also
sprich, das müsste ja dann 2021 H1 sein. Ah, First Half, okay. Ich dachte, das kommt
immer ziemlich am Anfang des Jahres raus. What's New? Die wissen jetzt schon, was neu
ist in 2021? Neue Emojis, ja, es wird ja auch Zeit. Übrigens, hier neue Emojis, wusstet
ihr, dass Microsoft, jetzt pass mal auf, Microsoft hat Custom Emojis, Hipster-Cat, gibt's nur
unter Windows. Hipster-Cat gibt's nur unter Windows. Hacker-Cat gibt's auch. Hacker-Cat
gibt's auch nur unter Windows. Also sprich, Microsoft hat's mittlerweile geschafft, sogar
proprietäre Emojis einzubauen in Windows. Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet. Ja, guck
mal, hier, so sieht's halt unter Windows aus. Und jetzt? Ach so, nee. Jetzt muss ich erst
mal Heftor zu starten, damit ich euch so die Unterlidung zeigen kann. Ja, edit, edit mal
Microsoft. Okay, bla, haben wir ge-edit, zack, power on. Ja, wir haben proprietäre Emojis
jetzt. Allerdings muss man echt mal Microsoft zugute halten. Ups, äh, hätte, Kacknoob.
Ah, ich war zu langsam. Ich weiß, dass man das nicht braucht, aber ich mach das immer
so reflexmäßig. Ah, zu langsam. Ich weiß, dass das anders geht. Ah, exzellent. Aber
ich freu mich immer, wenn ich, wenn ich den Disput-Menü erwische. So, also, zeig mal
hier. Stretched Guest Aspect. Okay, also, was, was kann man zur Auswahl zu booten? Ganz
normal Install-Medium, Boot, Traffic Save, okay, also geht nur das da. Schauen wir mal.
Mit Windows Key plus, ob die Emojis da drin sind, müssen wir mal gucken. Ich würde das
mal fast vermuten, ja. Ja. Wo sind sie? Neues Hexor Linux, ich kenn's nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aktuell ist Blackscreen Linux angesagt. Oh fuck, darf man das überhaupt sagen? Ein Blackscreen
Linux könnte ja schon, ist ja schon fast rassistisch hier. Kann man das Blackscreen, mein, mein
Bluescreen ist ja okay, aber Toss, Alter, ganz knapp vor. Band ist raus. So, also, was
wollen die von mir? Hast du vorhin BF4? Was BF4, du meinst BF3? Äh, ja, hab ich, ähm,
vor ein paar Stunden oder so, ja. Okay, das sieht auf jeden Fall schonmal fancy aus. Es
ist Saturday, 2. Januar, das ist schonmal richtig. Okay, also, inzunehmen wir das erstmal. Was
sie natürlich wieder überhaupt nicht hinkriegen, ist ordentlich lesbare Kontraste, ja. Man
muss nämlich dazu sagen, Darkseam allein ist überhaupt nicht das, was es ausmacht. Wichtig
ist, dass man immer noch alles gut lesen kann, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen. Also, bisschen
anstrengend ist es auf Dauer schon. Also, welcome to Heftor Linux. Clean computer with
Gparted before installing. Okay, Calamares Installation. Okay, wir sollen den Computer
cleanen, sagt er. Dann run man mal Gparted und cleanen alles. Exzellent, FAT32, gitt.
Warum denn FAT32? Alles weg hier. Delete. Delete. Delete. Delete. Accept. Jawoll, alles
gelöscht. Exzellent. Kann nix mehr schiefgehen. Okay, das ist überhaupt nicht, überhaupt
gar nicht aus, also die Farben und die Dinger und die Knubbel, die sind überhaupt nicht
inspiriert aus Mac OS oder so. Wobei unter Mac sind die Dinger links, oder? Ihr kennt
das wahrscheinlich besser, ich benutze Mac äußerst selten, unter Mac sind die links,
oder? Jap, okay. Chat kennt sich aus. Exzellent Chat. Okay, Calamares. Okay, da hört es mit
Darkseed schon mal. Guck dir mal, der sieht schon gar nicht mehr so passend aus jetzt.
Okay, American English. Nein, British English, bitteschön. Wobei, American English ist bei
der Sprache okay, aber bei den Einheiten hätte ich gerne nicht Kocona Freedom Units, weil
da wird das Gewicht von der Maus bei Amazon auch noch in Ounces gemessen und sowas. Man
weiß ernsthaft jemand, wie viel Ounces ein Gramm sind und wie viel Gramm, wie viel Gramm
ist man für ein Ounce, Ounce, Unce braucht, also immer. Übrigens, aber wisst ihr, wisst
ihr was ich weiß? Und jetzt, jetzt mal Chat IQ Test. Wenn das fehlschlägt, braucht man
mindestens 5 Pipesaps, um das wieder aufzuwiegen. Wie viel, wie viel Watt sind 1 PS? Wird gegoogelt.
120, nein, ganz weit weg von. Kann man das umrechnen? Ja, so halbwegs. Ein Mitch, das
ist gar nicht schlecht, das geht in die richtige Richtung. Ich bin mir jetzt, das Problem ist,
ich bin mir jetzt auch gerade jetzt, wo ich das gefragt habe, gar nicht mehr so hundertprozentig
sicher. Ich glaube auch irgendwas um 750 oder so. Ok, gucken wir mal kurz. Gucken wir mal,
gucken wir mal. Ok, 735, 735. Clocks HD hat gewonnen. Exzellent. Aber es war, es war,
es war, es war ein paar nah dran. Lass dich durchgehen, Chat. Prime Subs waren erfolgreich.
Fragt mal jetzt mal ohne Mist, ich sag das ja gar nicht, um beim Chat zu schleimen immer.
Fragt jeden anderen Twitch Chat, was das ist. Und keiner ist auch nur in der Nähe. Ich wette
mit euch, das müsste man ausprobieren. Geht mal in XQC Chat, wobei der Typ ist nicht doof.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, der könnte das wissen, da kann sich sehr viel, sehr viel
unsinnige Sachen merken. Ok, next. Also was, was möchte ich haben? Colonel without any
Nvidia. Gut, in der VM habe ich kein Nvidia. LTS. Ja, ohne Nvidia, unbedingt. Weiß zwar
nicht, ehrlich gesagt, so genau, warum das relevant ist, aber ok. Colonel ohne Nvidia,
in der VM ist es eh egal. Communication Software. Discord. Das ist ja die erste Distro, die
mich fragt, ob ich Discord installieren will. Das find ich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Was soll ich für Manjaro i3 für eine Linux-Version auswählen, sofern das relevant ist? Ich glaube,
ich hab einfach das ganz normale anderes Linux 4er Colonel oder 5er Colonel oder so ausgewählt.
Man kann es dir sagen. Ich glaube, man das hier überhaupt sieht. Ich glaube, das sieht
man hier gar nicht. Letztendlich ist es ziemlich egal. Ah, hier. Andere Linux 5er oder später
3er Colonel habe ich ausgewählt. Das macht aber keinen großen Unterschied. Discord kann
man auswählen. Q-Talks. Das sagt mir irgendwas. Das ist irgendein, was es auch schon eine
Weile gibt. Das ist irgendein Messenger oder sowas. Ich bin mir da aber nicht ganz sicher.
Ein Mitch fragt, bin ich mittlerweile einzigen, der auch Teamspeak benutzt? Nee. Nee. Wisst
ihr was, Leute? Wir machen mal kurz den Browser auf. Da, wo ich noch viel MMOs gespielt
habe, damals haben die Deutschen immer Teamspeak verwendet. Ein paar abgedrehte haben Mumble
verwendet, falls das noch jemand kennt. Aber die Deutschen haben immer Teamspeak verwendet.
Und wisst ihr, was die Amis verwendet haben? Leute, was meint ihr? Was meint ihr, was die
Amis damals, also die englischsprachige Community, Froggy hat es schon verraten. Aber es ist
nicht das einzige. Die haben Ventrilo verwendet. Genau. Das da. Und wenn ihr dachtet Teamspeak
sei schlecht, dann habt ihr noch nie Ventrilo verwendet. Und wisst ihr, was das Allerschlimmste
war, was manche auch verwendet haben damals? Wie ist das so? What the fuck? Geh weg. Alter,
was ist das da? Gibt es da überhaupt noch Screenshots von? Ja, oh mein Güte, das war
so schlecht, Alter. Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand? Das war richtig mies. Das hat auch
hauptsächlich die englischsprachige Community damals verwendet. Man hat wirklich schon
richtig viel Crap benutzt damals. Aber eins muss man echt sagen, eins hatte die Software
damals, was Software von heute weniger hat. Die hatte halbwegs gut durchdacht, also gut
optimierte Maustastaturbedienung und viele Optionen. Heute die Software ist ja darauf
ausgelegt, möglichst easy von irgendeinem Touchgerät bedient werden zu können und kaum
Optionen zu haben. Guckt euch den aktuellen Firefox an mit einem älteren Firefox. Egal,
wir sind etwas abgeschwiffen. Be unreal. Drei Monate. Dankeschön für den IQ++ Subscription.
Okay. Also, was haben wir? Discord installieren wir. Brauchen wir zwar nicht, aber installieren
wir Teams? Können wir auch installieren? Okay. Tiger VNC. War Tiger VNC das Ding, nicht
das Ding, die versucht haben, irgendwie X zu erweitern für irgendwie 3D-Beschleunigung
oder sowas. Wire Desktop. Was ist Wire Desktop? Was ist das? Messenger? Das sieht aus wie Skype
mit einem Elektron-Interface. So, als will ich es nicht verwenden. Ich glaube, das will
man nicht. Zoom. Zoom. Ist jemand bei euch in der unglücklichen Situation Zoom verwenden
zu müssen? Warum kann man keinen Snapchat installieren? Stimmt, Snapchat gibt es ja
für den Desktop gar nicht. Ja? Oh, ihr Arme. Zoom, Alter. Zoom ist so das typische Programm,
was man rausgebracht hat und nicht mit dem Erfolg gerechnet hat. Stay01. Dankeschön
für den Sub. Okay, machen wir mal weiter. Okay, Skype verbüßen ist aber auch ähnlich
schlecht. Okay, WebX. Also, WebX ist nur wirklich 2005. Ja, WebX haben wir früher auch verwendet.
Okay, Teams und Discord. Ich will einfach nur wissen, ob das aktuelle Version funktioniert.
Skype for Linux stable Slack. Okay, alles klar. Next. Development. Wollen wir davon
irgendwas installieren? Ja, Visual Studio Code. Ich mag den Installer. Das gefällt
mir, dass man einfach schon auswählen kann, was von dem ganzen Crap man haben will. Oh,
wait. Ich glaube, das ist das offizielle Microsoft Visual Studio. Und das ist, okay, also ein
bisschen Hilfetext wäre schon nicht verkehrt. Ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist das offizielle
Microsoft Visual Studio und das ist die Microsoft-fizierte Visual Studio Code Variante. Aber ein bisschen
was dahinter schreiben, hätte man schon können. Ich weiß das auch nur, weil mir die AUER-Repos
und wie spricht man die Dinge eigentlich aus? Art User Repos. Irgendwie bekannt vorgekommen.
Die AUER-Repos, ob da der Bauer was mit zu tun hat. So. A-U-R-Repos. Repos. AUER. Okay,
aber next. Was haben wir sonst noch? So, Prackets. Prackets, verwendest du das? Prackets war
ein richtig nicer Editor, als er rausgekommen ist mit diesem HTML-Live-Editing. Ich glaube,
hat bis heute noch keiner so gut hingekriegt. Notepad QQ. Atom rein. Warum soll ich Atom
reinmachen? Oder Atom, wie die coolen Leute sagen, ja. Kein Android Studio. Du kannst
Android Studio garantiert nachinstallieren. Das ist eh sehr unvollständig, weil man mal
ehrlich sagen muss, PyCharm ist dabei. Ach, es gibt eine PyCharm Community Edition? Warum
gibt, da fühle ich mich jetzt aber benachteiligt als.NET-Entwickler. Warum gibt es eine PyCharm
Community Edition und keine Rider Community Edition? Was soll das? Doch, IntelliJ ist
auch dabei. Stimmt, NeoWimp fehlt auch. Weil MS-Leute Geld haben wollen. Ja, aber das ist
doch gar nicht von Microsoft. Egal, weiter. Also Office aus Prinzip nichts. Was? Money
Dance. Was zum Teufel ist Money Dance? Das könnte, das könnte irgendein, das könnte
von Money Boy sein. Money Dance. Ich meine, wobei Money Boy hat jetzt eine Kochshow. Guckt
ihr mal die Kochshow ab und zu von Money Boy? Wie hieß das Ding noch mal? Kitchen? Ich
habe es wieder vergessen. Trap House Kitchen, genau. Ok, das ist irgendeine Stocksoftware,
die ich nicht haben will. Was will denn der Browser die ganze Zeit von mir? Ok, wir installieren
aus Prinzip keine Office-Software, weil ihr kennt mich, Office-Software braucht man
nicht. Multimedia brauchen wir jetzt hier auch nichts. Aber es ist cool, dass man Kodi
mit installieren kann. Schon mal nice. Inklusive Addons. Sollen wir mal gucken, ob da auch
der TV-Headend-Addon dabei ist? Will ich mal gleich ausprobieren. OBS kannst du mit
installieren. Weil man kann das auch alles nachinstallieren, das ist ja kein Ding. Das
hat, das hat, ich sag mal so, das sind im Prinzip die ganz normalen User-Repos, die
sie da hinzufügen wahrscheinlich oder was auch immer. Das kann man, das kann ich oder
manch Aro kann ich exakt die gleichen Sachen nachinstallieren. Das ist einfach nur für
Convenience, ja. Chrome, Chromium, Firefox, ok. FileZilla. Ist das nicht irgendein Torrent-Ding?
War das nicht Torrent? Oder bring ich jetzt durcheinander? Nein, Deluge, Deluge, Deluge,
wie auch immer das ausspricht. Poggers, das Torrent, ja. Hexchat, nice. IRC für die Boomer
unter uns, ja. Cute Browser ist am Start. Zebaro, komm, kommt da Zebaro? Brauchen wir
den Cute Browser, Leute? Garantiert ist das, Pacman. Das ist, ich bin mal gespannt, was
sie für User-Repos verwenden. Ich hab mich ja da mittlerweile auf Jay da ein bisschen
eingeschossen. Pigeon, das war früher voll angesagt, zu Zeiten, wo man auch ICQ und so
verwendet hat, weil das konnte mehrere Sachen. Na gut, weiter. Gaming, Minecraft-Launcher.
Sauerbraten ist am Start, jawoll. Das beste Game. Und wo ist SuperTuxKart? Play on Linux,
Sauerbraten, Ludris, ExtremeTuxRacer. Xonotic, Xonotic kenn ich nicht. Was ist Xonotic?
Die meisten Open-Source-Games sehen halt echt aus, wie von 1998 oder so. Okay, deswegen
zu eins auf Quake gemachtes. Alter, der Browser nervt mich jetzt schon. Okay, next. Utilities,
was brauchen wir? Wireshark, klar, Wireshark braucht man immer. Putty, also jetzt mal ernsthaft,
das letzte, was ich mir unter die Lidung installieren muss, ist, glaube ich, Putty, oder? Ich bin
ja begeistert, dass es das überhaupt gibt. Das System-D-Manager. Octopi, okay. Open-VM-Tools,
die müssen wir auf jeden Fall installieren, dass das hier Fullscreen geht, klar. Übrigens,
was ich auch gut finde, dass sie in ihrem Live-ISO die VM-Tools drinne haben, dass das
hier gleich auf Fullscreen geht. Firewall-Geschissen. Albert kann man installieren, genau. ZSH, Virtual
System, USB, A. Das sind jetzt Kroppen, oder was? Nee, davon will ich nichts installieren.
Davon will ich auch nichts installieren. Ich verwende immer Tuna als Firemanager, den gibt
es hier gar nicht. Was taugt ihr davon? Nemo? Keine Ahnung. Brauchen wir alles weglassen.
Der von KDE, das ist der, ne? Oder ist Nemo? Gar nicht. Egal, ich verwende das eh nicht.
ZSH, please. Das Problem an ZSH ist, ohne Config sagt es, finde ich, und ich will jetzt
hier nicht irgendeine komische, fette Default-Config draufpappen. Terminals, Gnome-Terminal, ja,
muss. TMAX muss auch. USB-Edger, kannst du auch gleich mit drauf machen. Ist eigentlich
eine coole Sache. ZSHIT. Hau mal, ZSHIT. Nur die echten Hacker-Mens nennen es ZSHIT.
USB, fun, Password-Manager, KeyPass? Ja, ich find das eigentlich ganz nice, dass wir dies
so gemacht haben, nicht dass man es bräuchte, weil jeder der mal 5 Minuten unter An Hebrews
was gemacht hat, kann es im user-re dev post nachinstallieren als NG aber warum nicht?
Okay, Europe, Berlin, alles klar. Systemlanguage, ich möchte eigentlich noch meinen Keyboard
Ach das kommt jetzt gleich. Mein Keyboardlayout einschätzen.
Number and Locals... Guck mal hier!
Der ist richtig...
GitGut. Du kannst den alias anlegen.
Dann kannst du das machen.
Ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Git... Das muss ich mal aufschreiben. Das ist ein richtig nicees Ding.
Wenn ich mal in...
Das... Ich mach GitGut alias Script oder so.
Ich mach in den Script, was unter GitGut irgendwas halbwegs Sinnvolles macht.
Und dann mach ich das auf GitHub. Easy 500 Sterne.
Aber was ich hier auch schon mal ganz gut finde...
Dass die so schlau sind und sagen, ok...
Du willst als Sprache Englisch, aber als Units, Einheiten, Currency und so...
Willst du keine Freedom Units, sondern ordentliche Einheiten, wie es in Deutschland gibt.
Hast du WLAN-Steckdosen, die man mit einem Pi... Mit einem Pi steuern kann?
Eine?
30 oder so.
Allerdings kannst du die jetzt nicht unbedingt nur mit einem Pi steuern.
Sondern mit jedem x-beliebischen Ding, was im WLAN hängt.
Was hältst du von der Opsi-Software-Verwaltung?
Kenn ich nicht.
Opsi.
Opsi klingt nach... Klingt so... Es sagt mir gar nichts.
Opsi klingt so ein bisschen nach...
Irgendwas von einer deutschen Firma.
Was die Marketing-Abteilung...
Beziehungsweise dort das Sales...
Die Sales-Leute verkauft haben.
Und ihr jetzt an der Backe habt und du das irgendwie ausbauen musst.
Ach so, kenn ich nicht. Nee.
Was ist das?
Open-System-Integration. Nee, kenn ich nicht. Sagt mir gar nichts.
Was für ein Monster-Router hast du?
Ich hab gar keinen Monster-Router.
Ich hab ne Mikrotik-Hex-POE.
Und für VoIP und Gedöns die billigste Fritzbox aller Zeiten.
Und ganz vorne halt das Unity-Media-Ding.
Welche Steckdosen verwendest du da?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Und ich würde dir das auch zeigen. Die Sache ist nur die...
Dass die Steckdosen, die ich verwende...
Mit der aktuellen Firmware nicht mehr empfehlenswert sind.
Also ich hab ein paar Steckdosen-Leisten.
Von Kogeek heißt der Hersteller.
Das ist ja nicht der Hersteller.
Im Prinzip sind das alles Tuya-Steckdosen-Leisten.
Ich hab dann diesen Vierer-Pack, den wir im Stream mal geflasht haben.
Das Problem ist...
Ich kauf mir diese Dinger.
Immer nur, wenn es gerade eine Lücke in der Firmware gibt.
Oder bekannt ist, ob man da Custom-Firmware drauf machen kann.
Und ich kann dir keine mehr empfehlen.
Weil die meisten aktuell nicht mehr geflasht werden können mit Custom-Firmware.
Und bei diesen Steckdosen-Leisten und Steckdosen...
Will man eigentlich Custom-Firmware haben.
Bei diesen normalen Tuya-Steckdosen-Leisten.
Weil ansonsten kannst du die nur über die China-App...
Über die China-Cloud mit der offiziellen China-App steuern.
Und das ist natürlich totaler Müll.
Man will die ja über das eigene WLAN steuern können.
Über ein Web-Interface oder die Heim-Automatisierung oder sowas.
Aber ich kann jetzt mal zeigen, zum Beispiel...
Äh, tja, ähm...
Haben wir irgendwie...
Eine IP von einer Steckdosen-Leiste?
Ich weiß jetzt gerade keine.
Hier.
Da, bäm.
Da ist eine Steckdosen-Leiste zum Beispiel.
Die kann ich steuern hier übers WLAN.
Da muss ich aber aufpassen. Ich glaube, das ist die...
Wo ich gerade mein ganzes Zeug hier für den Stream auch dran hab.
Die sollte ich nicht an- und ausschalten.
Hast du ein eigenes WLAN für deine Steckdosen-Leisten?
Ja.
Ach so.
Nee.
Ich hab' nen IoT-WLAN.
Ich hab' nen extra...
Da sind auch die ganzen China-Kameras drin.
Trotz Custom-Firmware.
Äh, was willst du probieren?
Hab' ich was übersehen?
Ha!
Ich bin dafür, dass man per Channel-Post...
Oh, wirklich!
Ruby!
Das ist ne gute Idee, das schreib ich mir auf.
Ich hab' ne gute Idee, das schreib ich mir auf.
Bzzzt.
Der scheiß Knob.
Der Typ hat echt Eindruck hinterlassen.
Wenn der wüsste...
Dass ich das jetzt hier 300 Leuten erzählt hab'.
Okay.
Also wir installieren den Kram jetzt erstmal weiter.
Next.
Keyboard.
Keyboard soll...
Cherokee, natürlich, was sonst.
Ist das nicht ein Auto?
Ist das nicht irgendein fettes Auto?
Ihr wisst, ich hab' von Autos keinen Plan.
No Dead Keys.
Bestimmt im Chat der Gnome-Typ.
Oh, das glaub' ich nicht.
No Dead Keys.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das ein Indianer-Stamm ist.
Deswegen, ja.
Ich brauch unbedingt das Indianer-Tastatur-Layout.
Replace Partition.
Erase Disk.
Jawoll.
Swap.
Wir brauchen Swap.
Wir haben 8G RAM.
Das reicht.
MBR.
Okay, das kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an BIOS.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an, was wir gebootet haben.
Okay.
Ist aber auch egal.
40G für Heftor Linux.
Alles klar.
Next.
User.
What's your name?
Cute.
Chat.
Oh, nee.
So.
Alles klar.
Name of this computer.
Cute Chat Forever Virtual Platform.
Genauso muss es heißen.
Das ist ein bisschen lang vielleicht.
Elevenhead.
Passwort.
123456.
Log in automatically.
Ja.
Jawoll.
Passwort für Root.
Vielleicht sollte man das Root-Account nennen.
Ich bin Administrator.
Die meisten Leute können mit Administrator oder Linux nix anfangen.
Was ist eigentlich Swap?
Das ist das, was unter Windows Auslagerungsdatei ist.
Also wenn der RAM voll ist, wo man dann quasi die Festplatte als RAM verwenden kann.
Oder halt irgendwas anderes als RAM.
Man könnte natürlich auch, was jetzt natürlich schon ziemlich sinnlos ist, aber man könnte auch eine RAM-Disk erstellen.
Und auf der RAM-Disk ein Swap-File anlegen.
Und dann das Swap-File als Swap mounten.
Das würde funktionieren.
Was aber reichlich sinnlos ist.
Hast du dir mal Ping-FS angeguckt?
Nein.
Was ist?
Ping?
Stores your data in ICMP.
Oh, was ist das?
True Cloud Storage.
Ping-FS.
Filesystem, where data is stored only in the Internet etc.
Ja.
Das heißt, der pingt sich unendlich lang oder was?
Das heißt, der pingt einfach unendlich lang.
Und dadurch ist, also der pingt halt jegliche Daten immer unendlich lang hin und her oder was?
Das ist geil.
Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Setz dich gleich mal auf meine To-Do-List.
Ping-FS.
Besten Dank.
Bis bald.
Ping-FS.
Beste.
Next Level Big Brain, ja.
Okay.
Also.
Next.
Also Summary.
Wir wollen uns auf Europe setzen, Deutsch, Englisch, Tastatur passt.
Erase.
Eine neue MS-DOS-Partition-Table.
Natürlich, Bill Gates wird sich freuen.
Install.
Oh.
Was?
Die haben nicht wirklich so einen Wizard gemacht, oder?
Wo die jetzt irgendwelche komischen, naja, ich will es nicht mal 3D-Renders nennen,
weil du irgendwie so komischen Dinger hast.
Es gibt halt nur zwei Bilder, ne?
Mehr als zwei Bilder gibt es erstmal nicht.
Zwei Bilder müssen reichen dafür.
Und was ist das hier für komisches Ninja-Zeug da nebendran?
Ja.
Das könnte, die Leute, die das da nebendran können, irgendwie so Naruto-Cosplay sein oder
so.
Ich hab nie großartig Naruto geguckt.
Ich kenn bloß so ein paar Clips auf YouTube.
Und das ist ja bei Naruto wohl irgendwie normal, dass die 50 Augen haben und 90 Schwänze
und 500 Finger und sowas und sich da gegenseitig bashen.
Also es könnte wirklich irgendwie so, ja oder irgendwie irgendwelche komischen Sandkugeln
werden und sowas, ja.
Dann kann das auch so sein.
Gatschi-Hyper.
Stop talking.
Ja, wie stimmt das etwa nicht?
Ich kenne nur ein paar Ausschnitte auf YouTube.
Und da übertreiben sie es halt mit Fähigkeiten auch wieder extrem.
Ich glaube, es ist eher so ne, es ist bestimmt, es ist bestimmt ne Serie, wo die halt angefangen
haben, ohne sich darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber wo sie sich am Anfang keine Gedanken drüber gemacht haben, dass das irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre läuft und am Ende irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nen Furz zwei Planeten
zerstört und deswegen mussten sie sich sehr merkwürdige Erklärungen überlegen am Ende,
warum die Leute so stark sind.
Das ist das, was mir auch an Dragon Ball auf den Keks geht.
Das ist exakt genauso.
Ja, das hab ich auch gelesen, dass das jetzt fertig ist, ja.
Das hab ich auch mitbekommen.
One Piece hab ich gar nicht mehr verfolgt.
Ich hab früher ab und zu mal ein bisschen geguckt, ihr wisst ja, ich bin kein allzu großer
Anime-Gucker, ein paar hab ich geguckt, aber nicht so wahnsinnig viele.
One Piece hab ich früher ab und zu ein bisschen geguckt und ich hab letztens mal wieder, als
ich auf einer selbstverständlich furchtbar legalen Streaming-Seite gewesen bin, in eine
aktuelle Folge reingeguckt und irgendwie, oh ist der jetzt fertig?
What is happening?
Installier mal.
Ja, zumindest, ich hab letztens in eine halbwegs aktuelle Folge oder so mal wieder reingeguckt.
Irgendwie sehen jetzt alle ganz anders aus und haben absolut, also ich mein, das waren
schon immer abgedrehte Fähigkeiten, aber jetzt komplett abgedrehte Dinger, somit, somit,
somit, somit, somit, somit Dampfantrieb und sowas.
What the fuck?
Keine Ahnung mehr, ich hab da nicht weiter geguckt.
Nee, ich weiß was, das war, wenn man scrollt, wenn man scrollt mit der Maus, dann switcht
er die Desktops.
Okay, aber die zwei, ich mein, immerhin haben sie zwei stylische Installer-Bilder, ist ja
schon mal was.
Wir haben übrigens gerade 256 Zuschauer.
Excellent.
Kann man Linux in PingFS installieren?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie PingFS funktioniert, aber ich vermute mal nicht, weil PingFS was
ist, was darauf aufsetzt, dass schon was da ist.
Was ist denn die Mod-Teste?
Was?
Ich verstehe nicht, was du meinst.
Was denn die Mod-Taste ist?
Die Mod-Taste?
Mod-Check?
Achso, nee, das ist die Windows-Taste, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Ich war ein schlechter Chebat-Versuch von mir.
Das ist die Windows-Taste.
Du kannst das ummappen, aber in der Regel ist das die Windows-Taste.
Auch Super genannt manchmal.
Oder war Super alt?
Habt ihr mich verwirrt, Leute?
Nee, ich glaube Super und Mod ist...
Also Mod ist im Prinzip das, was du konfiguriert hast als Mod-Taste und normalerweise ist es
eben Super, also die Windows-Taste standardmäßig.
Man kann das beispielsweise unter E3 remappen, dass man zum Beispiel Alt verwendet anstatt
Windows-Taste, aber in der Regel kann es vorausgehen, dass es die Windows-Taste gemeint.
Installing 4 Packages, exellent.
Alt ist Mod 1, ja, stimmt, ja, hast recht.
Und was ist...
Das macht eine ganz dofe Frage.
Wow.
Das ist aber hier mal next level.
Was ist eigentlich das für eine Taste?
Hier, während das installiert, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung für die Daseinsberechtigung
von...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Logitech G513.
Die Daseinsberechtigung von dieser Taste.
Von der da.
Also ich weiß, dass die Menüs aufmacht, aber wozu braucht man das?
Warum ist die auf jeder Tastatur drauf?
Könnte man die nicht sinnvoller verwenden?
Könnte man nicht zum Beispiel eine extra breite Control-Taste machen, dass man besser
crouchen kann in Games?
Fallback für defekte Maus, also ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte mehr defekte Tastaturen als defekte
Maus bisher.
Vor 60 Jahren, okay, wirkt top aktuell, dass man die braucht, ja.
Rechtes Control für crouch.
Klar, wenn du einen 15 cm langen Daumen hast, dann schon.
Cobalt hast du.
Ja, Screenlock ist auch richtig sinnlos, braucht halt auch keiner mehr.
Das ganze Zeug braucht keiner mehr.
Okay, das brauchst du unter Windows noch, um Screenshots zu machen, aber ansonsten.
Das brauchst du nimmer.
Damit konntest du früher pausen beim booten.
Was das macht, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Und ich bin ja übrigens Fan von NumBlock.
Gibt ja viele mittlerweile, die sagen NumBlock ist useless und die kaufen sich eine kurze
Variante von einer Tastatur ohne NumBlock.
Aber ich mag NumBlock.
Weiß nicht, wie es mit euch aussieht, Chat, ob ihr eher NumBlock oder Anti-NumBlock seid.
Aber ich kann ohne NumBlock nicht.
NumBlock muss NumBlock, ja.
Vor allem, wisst ihr, was die Taste ist beim NumBlock, die ich ja meist verwende?
Von allen denen hier.
Außer die NumBlock an und aus Taste, weil es meistens nicht an ist.
Aber die meist benutzte Taste ist Enter.
Ist echt so.
Die meist benutzte NumBlock Taste ist Enter bei mir.
Sexyrexy135.
Exquisite Subscription, Dankeschön.
IQ++.
NumBlock ist useless, nein NumBlock ist beste.
Frag meine Kasiererin, ob der NumBlock useless ist.
Du nutzt Sternchen und Slash, ok.
Haben wir es heute eigentlich noch mal mit installieren?
Die große Leertaste ist sinnlos.
Ja, teilweise schon.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin ja jemand, der gerne in...
Warum ist die Musik gerade so laut?
Ich bin ja jemand, der darauf schwört, Jump auf Space zu haben.
Obwohl ja die richtig coolen Pros in Spielen, wo gesprungen wird, mittlerweile den Jump alle auf Mausrad haben.
Aber ich bin nicht so cool, ich habe Jump nicht auf Mausrad.
All done.
Und da finde ich es ganz gut, wenn man easy mit dem Daumen irgendwo in die Mitte haut und kommt auf die Leertaste.
Ok, all done, Restart now, done, bam.
Jump auf Recht, echt?
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Da sind wir, bam.
Das ging schnell.
Heftor Edition Welcome App.
Twitch, die machen es richtig.
Guck mal, hier kannst du dem Heftor Entwickler einfach mal auf Twitch zugucken.
Sagenhafte zwei Follower hat er.
Excellent.
Password for Keyring, 123456, 123456, continue, excellent, details.
Das nervt schon mal rum mit Updates, was sehr gut ist.
Also, das Dark Theme gefällt mir inklusive dem Hintergrund.
Was ich nicht ganz so gelungen finde, ist der Kontrast der Schrift.
Weil einen dunkel-grau-blauen Hintergrund und eine etwas hellere, dunkle-grau-blaue Schrift ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Aber hier kann man updaten.
Wie updatet man denn?
Da.
123456.
Ups, habe ich die vertippt?
Wie kann man sich bei 123456 vertippen?
Das geht anscheinend möglich.
So, dann gibt es noch YouTube-Channels von denen.
Restart is required.
Okay, restarten wir.
Ist jetzt kaputt.
YouTube.
YouTube ist auch am Start.
Breadhavenen.
50 Subs, GitHub.
Heftwars.
Und Donate in PayPal kann man auch.
Exzellent.
Das sollten mehrere Distros machen in der Richtung.
Ein bisschen Eigenwärmung ist nicht verkehrt.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit, wo Social Media Präsenz alles ist, um irgendwie bekannt zu werden, ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Okay, kann ich jetzt hier direkt drüber restarten?
Wie kann ich hier überhaupt restarten?
Jetzt wird es komplex.
Wie restarte ich, da drüber?
Nee.
Ha.
Ich meine, ich kann einen Terminal aufmachen und Rebooten, aber das ist wahrscheinlich nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Ah, da oben.
Da oben.
Aber das ist halt auch kontrastmäßig fragwürdig hier oben, ne?
Restart.
Das North Theme.
Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar mal eine Weile verwendet.
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor, als wo du es gerade schreibst.
Nee, nee, nee.
Habe ich nicht.
Habe ich nichts anderes.
Ich verwende eigentlich fast überall irgendeine Base 16 Tomorrow Night Variante.
So.
Okay, jetzt haben wir installiert.
Qt Browser hat Wim-artige Tastenkombination.
Das ist doch gut.
Jetzt ist natürlich die...
Hier ist der Qt Browser.
Nee.
Ha.
She baited.
Es ist Qbit Torrent.
Es ist nicht der Qt Browser.
So, hat das Ding ein Startmenü oder sowas?
Hat das Ding in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Startmenü?
Da oben vielleicht?
Ah.
Der hat sich versteckt hinter dem...
Da müssen wir mal kurz ausblenden.
Ah.
Ja, ja.
Leute, das Nvidia-Ding hat meine Tastatur gefressen.
Meine Maus geht nicht mehr.
Das Nvidia-Ding hat meine Maus gefressen.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt brauchen wir Big Brain.
Was können wir jetzt machen?
Nee, nee.
Kontext-Menü bringt mir nichts.
Ich komm' da, krieg' da keinen Fokus drauf.
Okay.
Was, was können wir jetzt machen?
Nee, nee.
Alter, 4 bringt nichts.
Okay.
Was machen wir jetzt, Leute?
Big Brain.
Big Brain, Big Brain, was, was machen wir jetzt?
Chain, Task Manager, Task Manager geht nicht.
Nee, nee, es geht in Windows D, Windows R geht alles nicht.
Okay, okay, das, okay, Mal Tastatur, Mal Maus rein raus.
Erst mal okay, Mal Tastatur rein raus, vielleicht reicht das ja schon.
Hopp.
Okay, das sagt jetzt natürlich mal richtig.
Äh, ich muss mal kurz hinter den Rechner, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich die Maus ein...
Ich mach einfach ne zweite Maus dran.
Wartet mal.
Exzellent Idee. Exquisite Idee, ich mach jetzt einfach ne zweite Maus dran.
Ha. Geht nicht.
Okay, jetzt natürlich doof.
So, jetzt die andere Maus rein und raus.
Jetzt, und jetzt, nee, nee, ja, ja, kommt, das geht, aber, aber dann...
Jetzt, jetzt hab ich echt ein Problem, ne.
Ha.
Da sind wir wieder.
Bam.
Wir sind wieder am Start, Leute.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Start.
Was hab ich gemacht?
Ich hab gesagt Switch User, Switch User und bin dann wieder raus.
Okay, jetzt mach ich das mal aus.
Off, off.
Und jetzt geht's wieder.
Alles klar. So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ich hab das Startmenü gesucht, da oben, genau.
Okay, das ist so ein ganz normales XFCE Startmenü, was haben wir da? Der Qt Browser, da isser.
Oh.
Sieht ja schon mal...
Okay, man kann wenigstens ordentlich resize'n, ja.
Qt Session Warning.
Okay, es sind Wim, es sind, also, es sind Wim Shortcuts, habt ihr gesagt.
Also, das heißt, ich geh jetzt mal, keine Ahnung, auf YouTube.
Oh, nee, das ist...
Insert Mode, what the fuck?
Okay, das heißt auch, ich kann Escape drücken und dann kann ich Doppelpunkt machen.
Also, auf die New Tab. Tab.
Okay, das ist, okay, warum nicht, warum nicht, ja.
Okay.
Suche mich mal auf YouTube.
Ah, guck mal jetzt, ui, boah, das ist ja Big Brain Logik. Jetzt kann ich...
Äh, äh, äh, äh, GT, nee, fuck, was, was, was, was ist back in Wim? Äh, R.
Nee, R ist reload in dem Fall.
Ähm, wie komm ich in der Seite zurück?
Ja, da wird schon kompliziert.
Back.
Control.
Undo.
Nee.
Ach, watsch, Moment, R, R war in Replace. Wie komm ich jetzt auf R gerade?
Groß R ist Redo, genau.
Control O, nee.
Zumindest, man kann navigieren, guck mal.
Wenn ich jetzt, im Angenomm, ich benutze die Maus jetzt nicht.
Kann ich F drücken und jetzt mach ich GL, dann klickt er den ersten Link für mich an.
F, mal gucken, ob wir so YouTube navigiert kriegen, ey.
Ha, ha.
Oh, das ist ja verboten, haben wir letztens beim Nummernschild gelernt.
So, F, I, okay, wie kann ich jetzt agreeen?
Wie agree ich jetzt hier?
L, F, K?
Nein.
Tja, wo wir wieder mal an meinem Punkt sind,
man kann Browser nur gescheit mit einer Tastatur, äh, mit einer Maus bedienen.
K, K. Nee.
Hm.
S, J? Tja.
Cute browser versus pop-up.
Also, ich bleib dabei, das ist ja auch das, was ich immer drauf sage,
wenn die Leute mir erzählen, ja, aber in meinem Vim,
da bin ich immer mit meinen Fingern auf der Home Row
und ich kann immer, ähm, superschnell navigieren in meinem Vim.
Und dann ist meine erste Frage, ist ja, und?
Was machst du, wenn du mal im Browser was nachgucken musst?
Ja, und dann kommen sie an mit, ja, ich hab irgendeinen Vim Addon oder sonst was.
Das Problem ist aber, dass du mit, äh,
Tastaturbedienung only haltenden Browser, ehrlich gesagt, kacke bedienen kannst.
Als Ergänzung ist es ganz cool, ja.
Zum Beispiel ist es für mich jetzt viel einfacher, D, H zu tippen oder sowas.
Oder, oder hier S, A für Startseite.
Guck, aber das Pop-up, L, H, K. L, H, K. ist no thanks.
Okay, das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Oh, das Piano Grill.
So, äh, so, jetzt Pop-up hat sich erledigt.
Review Now will ich jetzt anklicken, F, A.
F, I agree. Was ist I agree?
L, G, L, ne.
Lull, auch nicht.
Okay, es ist, es geht halt nicht.
Man kann halt, man kann halt einfach kein Browser,
was ist das?
Das ist broken.
Guck mal, ich kann den Browser nicht zumachen.
Okay, das geht ja schon mal gut los.
Das geht ja schon mal gut los.
Ist dieser Dialog dann überhaupt accessible?
Was machen blinde User bei diesem Dialog?
Ich glaube, YouTube ist nicht optimiert für blinde Benutzer.
So kacke ist es, ich glaube, das juckt YouTube nicht.
Was ich aber nicht verstehe, ehrlich gesagt,
das sollte sie nämlich jucken, weil YouTube eine super Plattform ist,
immer auch für Sehbehinderte blinde zu konsumieren.
Es gibt ja auch viele Sachen, die man sich einfach anhören kann.
Und YouTube tut, und generell Google tut immer so wahnsinnig exklusiv
und make a change und sonst was.
Da könnten sie ihre Seiten aber zumindest mal für Sehbehinderte optimieren.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, welches Betriebssystem empfiehlst du für einen NAS-Server?
Auf welcher Hardware denn?
So, kann ich jetzt, ah, jetzt darf ich den Qt-Browser zumachen, aber sonst?
Fuck.
Okay, das buggt.
Ah, das geht, ah, Moment, das geht nach einer Zeit weg.
Jetzt versteh, ups, jetzt versteh ich das.
Das geht nach einer Zeit weg.
Aber, aber, ja, aber das ist, das ist usability kompletter Müll.
Ich mein, ich mach doch, guck mal, wenn ich, Leute, wenn ich das Fenster zumach,
dann ziel ich doch nicht mit der Maustaste erst auf dieses kleine Furzding da oben.
Da schmeiß ich den Mausteig in die rechte obere Ecke und klick drauf.
Nee, ich hab noch nie ein anderes Tastatoli-Out ausprobiert.
Normaler Rechte, dann im Ubuntu-Server. Ich mag Ubuntu-Server.
Äh, Sebastian Keller, ich glaub, das hab ich sogar schon mal verwendet.
Da kann man, also falls das das ist, oder es gibt bestimmt noch andere,
da kann man Wim verwenden, wenn man in dem Textfeld was editiert und so.
Das ist tatsächlich cool, ja.
Integriertes Aim-Training. Ja, im Prinzip ist das sowas.
Aber das ist nervig. Alter, das, das, das nervt, das geht mir jetzt schon,
vor allem geht's jetzt nicht mehr weg, das, das geht mir jetzt schon extrem auf den Keks.
Da weiß ich jetzt schon, dass ich das nicht benutzen kann.
Da kling ich ja jedes Mal auf dieses komische Menü. Im Zweifelsfall mach ich sogar aus Versehen Restart.
Der ohne Nachfrage Restart, nur weil ich das Fenster zumachen will.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist, das ist, finde ich, nicht so gut gemacht.
Hallo dumme Frage, was meinst du, was als Einstiegsgehalt zum Physio-K ist?
Ja, kommt auf die Region an. Das kommt wirklich ganz extrem auf die Region an.
Das ist doch, Linux geht sicher irgendwie mit Sicherheit.
Aber ich installiere ja sowas hier gerade, dass ich nicht selbst rumfuddeln muss.
By the way, Desktop geht nicht mehr.
RIP, broken. Reboot hat nicht funktioniert. Shutdown.
Ich bin ja immer begeistert, wie einfach ich es schaffe, diese ganzen Distributionen zu zerstören.
Dabei mach ich ja gar nichts.
Ah, jetzt hat er es wieder gecheckt, ok.
Alles klar, weiter. Ok, was haben wir sonst noch drauf? Also Startmenü.
Probier doch mal Gentoo. Ich bin ja glücklich mit meinem, was ich hab.
So, den ganzen üblichen Krempel. Office, brauchen wir nicht.
Cute Capture Utility.
Ok, startet schon mal nicht, hat keinen Bock. Rechtsklick auf dem Desktop geht übrigens nicht.
Warum geht rechtsklick auf dem Desktop, was ist das hier unten?
Supply Text 3 Def. Hä, hab ich das vorhin ausgewählt? Nee, oder?
Ich hab doch vorhin kein Supply Text ausgewählt. Oh.
Ah, ok, das verschiebt keine Eigenschaft auf den Desktop, das löscht die Dinger.
Ok, damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Aber das geht aufs Desktop schieben. What? Ok, das ist ziemlich inkonsistent.
Ich kann das mit dem Startmenü was auf den Desktop schieben, aber aus der Leiste auf den Desktop löscht das.
Das ist ein Audio Visualizer, das ist eine gute Frage.
Machen wir mal VLC irgendwas an. VLC, äh, ja wir brauchen erstmal was zum Playbacken.
Was Playbacken wir denn mal? Ein Video von mir. Erstmal YouTube DL.
So, Gnome, Terminal. Zack.
Das ist unter Mac auch so...
Echt normal, dass das so...
Ah, Farbschema gefällt mir nicht wirklich gut. Ok.
Ah, ok. YouTube DL, das allerwichtigste, was wir erstmal runterladen müssen.
YouTube DL ist generalmäßig installiert. Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Ok, dann lad ich jetzt nämlich ein eigenes Video von mir runter.
Da kann er sich keiner Copyright-mäßig aufregen.
So. Zack. Paste.
YouTube DL.
Da.
So, und dann spielen wir das ab. Wo ist mein Filemanager?
Tuna! Sag ich doch, den will ich doch eigentlich haben. Was hatten wir denn noch zusätzlich installiert?
Ähm...
Tja.
Dolphin, oder?
Der sieht überhaupt nicht passend aus hier drinnen. Aber klar, ich meine, das ist ein KDE-Ding in irgendeinem GTK-Desktop.
Das sieht nicht wirklich passend aus.
Games.
Extreme Tux Racer. Jawoll!
Oh, diese High Quality Open Source Games wieder. Excessant Menschen, genau.
Das Sandmenschen, ja. Excess.
Tux Racer Classic Canadian Cup. Bunny Hill.
Oh!
Massive!
Also, also...
Also es ist ja, da ist ja RTX...
Ups. Das hab ich irgendwie ausgemacht.
Jetzt wollte ich gar nicht ausmachen.
Moment, noch mal.
Ok, Bunny. Bunny.
Ach, Select Your Player Name ist das. Racer.
Tux, Trixie, Boris...
Capri. Sieht ja ein schlimmer aus als das andere, Alter.
Configuration. Gibt's da noch mehr?
Exquisite Graphics. Level of Detail. Jawoll. Gibt's mir. Volle Pulle.
Level of Detail.
A4 ist Maximum. Ok.
Enter.
Continue.
Race.
Kann man springen oder so?
High Quality Open Source Games.
Übrigens, der springt, der springt erst wenn man die Leertaste loslässt.
Das ist total, total merkwürdig irgendwie.
Normalerweise springt man wenn man die Leertaste drückt und der springt erst wenn man die Leertaste loslässt.
Ganz merkwürdig, Alter.
Vor allem auch wie hoch.
Was springen beim Loslassen ist normal bei SSX. Was ist SSX?
Failed. Was?
Warum hab ich failed?
Ha. Sauerei.
Failed.
Ach so. Das ist das man quasi so, so, so...
Quasi je nachdem wie lang man das gedrückt hat, umso, umso mehr springt man quasi.
Kann man bremsen irgendwie? Oh Gott, ich kann bremsen.
High Quality 2D Fische. Hier, guckt euch mal den Fisch an.
Ok, näher. Ich muss wieder raus.
Was Sauerbraten, please. Sauerbraten könnten wahrscheinlich sogar ein paar Leute kennen.
Sauerbraten ist quasi Quake, Quake 3, nicht ganz so Quake 3-ig Remaked.
MrFixit, excellent.
Meine Maus geht nicht.
Ja, ich würd's, ich würd's ja gerne, gerne spielen, aber...
geht nicht.
Kann nix machen.
Ok. Gibt's so eine Art Taskmanager, um den Gramm zu killen?
Oder muss ich Xkill machen?
Bam. Schreckt.
Ok.
So, jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob das in der Mitte...
Der Knopf geht nicht.
Ah, Moment, der Knopf geht doch, das war...
Ok, das in der Mitte ist...
Hat mit dem laufenden Audio, mit dem laufenden Video in der Mitte nix zu tun.
Das ist, glaub ich, einfach nur Show.
Ja, du bist im Video, MrArmy, genau.
Irgendwo da warst du gerade, ja.
Ok, das hat damit nix zu tun.
Übrigens, das ist wirklich die Sache, wo sich Windows was von abschneiden könnte.
Die Linux-Suche funktioniert nicht deutlich besser als die Windows-Suche.
Das wirkt wieder so un...
Wie soll ich sagen, so zusammengesteckt, aber nicht richtig gepolished.
Schwer zu sagen.
So, hier oben haben wir dann unseren VLC, den kann man minimieren.
Maximieren, alles klar, ok.
Quit.
Muted.
Ah, ok, Audiomixer.
So ein übliches PR-Panel oder sowas.
Wie ein Manjaro auf Wish.
Es ist schon ganz gut gemacht, aber...
Übrigens...
What the fuck?
Ich kann von links unten nach...
Ich kann von rechts unten nach links oben ohne Probleme auf dem Desktop dieses Ding ziehen, ja.
Aber von links oben...
Seht ihr?
Ach, Moment.
Das ist nur, wenn ich hier draufklicke.
Das hier ist doch irgendein Bedienelement.
Und wenn ich hier draufklicke, kriege ich auch ein Rechtsklickmenü.
Hier nicht.
Ok, was macht das in der Mitte?
Ja, das ist das Musikoverlay.
Ich habe ja gerade versucht, das Musikoverlay anzubekommen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie.
Open File.
Ah.
So, ich habe jetzt ein Video vor mir laufen.
Ich habe es minimiert, aber da läuft nichts.
So, Musik ist aus.
Breitbandausbau in Deutschland.
Und ich habe jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre gewartet, seitdem ich das letzte Video gemacht habe.
Interessiert es nicht.
Soll ich das Video machen oder soll ich das Video nicht machen?
Weil ich muss sagen...
Ok, dann spielen wir das nochmal ab.
Wahrscheinlich nur Spotify.
Das ist irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht.
What the...
Ist der VLC jetzt gecrashed?
Hallo?
VLC, please?
Ok, du willst der Crap, Alter.
Ok, das Settings-Menü ist schon mal besser als das Windows-Settings-Menü.
Das ist aber auch geil.
Das ist aber auch kein Heftor-Gui.
Oh, was ist das?
Upgrade Bash?
Warum soll ich das machen?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es jetzt einfach mal gemacht.
Moment.
Darf man sowas mit ausliefern?
Das darf man bestimmt nicht mit ausliefern.
Das ist bestimmt TOS, wenn man das mit ausliefert.
Direkt Nintendo vor der Haustür und klopft an.
Wobei, das könnte sogar wirklich erlaubt sein.
Wenn es ein Custom-Fan-Art ist, dann könnte das durchaus erlaubt sein.
Squirtle.
Ok, wir haben ganz schicke Hintergründe.
Und da ist wieder dieses komische Ding.
Sieht aus wie aus Wolfenstein.
Die Discord ist dabei, nix im Trash.
BitTorrent weg.
Bis jetzt hat es mich nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt.
Ist das Ascii-Quarium drauf?
Gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber nachdem es ein vollwertiges Arch ist, kann man das Ascii-Quarium nachinstallieren.
Was ja bekanntlichermaßen das wichtigste ist, was man auf jeder Linux-Distro braucht.
Ah, yes.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Ok, wichtige Sachen sind schon mal dabei.
C-Matrix, ja das brauchen wir auch. Wir brauchen Matrix-Bildschirmschoner.
Bist du eigentlich ein Virtual-Reality-Fan? Ich habe keine 3D-VR-Brille.
Jawoll, jetzt ist der Hacker-Man glücklich.
Jetzt bräuchte man noch ordentliche Hacker-Man-Musik im Hintergrund und dann passt das.
Das freut den Jett.
SL, nee, nee, nee, SL brauchen wir nicht. Ascii-Quarium ist wichtiger.
SL ist ja die Bahn, die übers Terminal fährt, dann ist mir das Aquarium lieber.
SL ist sogar standmäßig drauf.
Ok, SL.
Wo ist das überhaupt?
Extra.
SL, wo ist es denn? Ok, einfach Pac-Man.
Jawoll, da ist er.
Was ist die Boot-Time? Das Booten geht tatsächlich relativ schnell, aber das sagt jetzt nichts aus, weil das ja inner-VM ist.
Das ist der Scam-Train, genau. Nee, man übrigens nicht canceln kann.
Drück Null in C-Matrix. Was passiert denn dann?
Bist du noch mit dem Friseur überfallen? Klar, wir kannten uns ja vorher auch schon.
Ah, yes. Wie macht man wieder langsamer? Ah, neun.
Das ist der Hacker-Man-Modus.
Ja, das macht die, das fuckt die Bitrate ab, ne, Leute. Da reichen vier MBit nicht.
Da kommt er nicht mit.
Ok, genug jetzt.
Ja, ok, das hat mich bis jetzt schon mal echt nicht überzeugt.
Wir probieren jetzt mal, ich mache jetzt hier gar nicht weiter, wir probieren jetzt mal die Tiling-Window-Manager-Variante.
Das ist ja für die richtigen Hacker-Mans unter uns.
Ich gucke aber vorher noch einmal schnell eine Sache. Was hat er denn bei Visual Studio Code für eine Version dabei?
Muss ja was halbwegs Aktuelles sein, wenn es aus dem User-Repo kommt. Ja, das ist aktuell.
Oh, cool. Sie haben die gleiche Tastenkombination wie ich unter I3 für Fenster schließen. Das ist schon mal gut.
Oder nicht. Ach ne, es ist einfach nur Windows-Q.
Das ist das normale, wie es Code, ja.
Übrigens, man kann den Knopf nicht klicken, weil man ganz oben links in der Ecke ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich immer so Dinge entdecke.
Ah doch, geht. Das liegt an, ok, ich habe nichts gesagt. Das liegt an der VM.
Das liegt an der VM. Das lag an der VM.
Teams Brip. Ist das immer noch Brip-View?
Salomon95, guckt doch mal in die letzten Videos auf dem Channel.
Da ist so ziemlich alles drin, was wir auf dem Stream so machen.
Da ist Battlefield am Start, da ist Technik-Stells am Start, da ist Cobalt am Start. Das ist ja alles am Start.
Wireshark. Ja, Wiresharks für die richtigen Hacker-Mans.
Aber ganz ehrlich, gut gefallen tut mir das nicht.
Date-Argo-Linux-Tweak-Tool. Ist aber nicht drauf, oder? Ah, doch.
Was für ein Kern, da können wir gucken, aber ein ziemlich aktueller, denke ich mal.
Top, das ist ziemlich neu. Ok. Aha. Und nun?
Select the Desktop. Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt hier, sagen wir mal,
den Kram nachinstalliere, dann sind es ja ohne die Settings von denen.
Auf welcher Distro passiert das jetzt in irgendein Archlinux? Oder Archlinux ist das.
E3 has not been installed, warum nicht? Was?
Better Log Screen and Better Log Screen Git are in Conflict.
Ne, das ist echt nicht gut, das ist nicht schön gemacht.
Crub-Themes, ok, das ist nice. Der Chat, was ist los?
Ok, wir haben jetzt zumindest ein nicest Boot-Wallpaper.
Blocker, Ad-Blocker, habe ich den Browser. Neofetch-Editor, Pacman-Config, Themes.
Ok, wir gucken uns nochmal das schöne Crub-Theme an.
Da ist es, nice. Aber Gandalf am Start im Crub, perfekt.
Der Chat, der scheiß Gnome. Wenn der Kerl wüsste, ey.
Und jetzt gehen die VMA-Tools wieder nicht, oder?
Ah, ok. Was? What the fuck, was geht hier gerade ab?
Und jetzt ist das Ding wieder links oben, nicht mehr in der Mitte?
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal links oben, eben war das doch noch in der Mitte.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ok, Leute, ich werde mir das jetzt nicht weiter angucken, ich installiere mir die andere Variante davon.
Ja, wahrscheinlich weil sich die Desktop-Auflösung geändert hat, aber man sollte eigentlich das so programmieren,
dass man die Auflösung resizen kann und es trotzdem noch funktioniert.
Ok, also, was wollen wir haben? Leute, was wollen wir verwenden?
BISP-WM oder HILL-WM?
Herbstluft, ich glaube das ist Herbstluft-WM. Der Name allein schon, Alter. Gnome.
Leute, wenn ich Gnome installiere, das macht ihr nur, dass ihr im Chat sagen könnt,
der scheiß Gnome, das weiß ich genau.
Keiner will...
Chat, Alter.
Scheiß Gnome, Alter.
Der Chat dreht voll am Rad, Alter.
Nur für den Chat installiere ich jetzt... Nein, ich starte nur die Live-CD.
Ich starte nur die Live-CD, das reicht. Wir müssen das nicht installieren.
Ok, äh, please download starten. Wir laden einfach beide schonmal runter.
Also, was HILL-WM wollten wir haben, ne? Danach.
Ok.
Also, die Distro hat mich bis jetzt nicht so wirklich überzeugt. Zumindest nicht in der XFCE-Variante.
Was habt ihr gegen Gnome? Nix.
Das hat überhaupt nichts mit Gnome Desktop zu tun.
Wir hatten mal ein Kollege auf der Arbeit. Ich muss jetzt vielleicht mal kurz...
Wir hatten einen Kollege auf der Arbeit, der hat seinen Desktop so eingestellt,
dass wenn er mit der Maus an den Bildschirmrand gekommen ist,
dass er einen PC-Speaker gesummt hat. Das heißt, er ist an den Bildschirmrand gekommen und
seinen PC-Speaker hat gemacht...
So, und dann hat er immer gesagt, es wäre der Gnome, der Scheiße eingestellt ist.
Das wäre quasi sein Gnome Desktop, der das macht. Das heißt, es hat gerade...
Und dann hat er gesagt, der Scheiß Gnome. Jedes Mal.
So, fünf Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub. Sorry, Leute, falls ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen hab. Ich war gerade zu abgelenkt durch den Scheiß Gnome.
Ich scroll mal schnell durch. Der Chat ist ja so auf dem Rumspam mit dem Schwarz.
Ich glaube, ich hab nix übersehen.
It's Veto. Zu NRW kann ich nicht viel sagen.
Ruby Stream. Ruby Stream können wir jederzeit machen. Ruby, beste Programmiersprache neben C-Sharp.
Zumindest meine Lieblingssprache neben C-Sharp.
So, hat er downloaded? Nein, hat er noch nicht ganz downloaded.
Oh man, aber das hat sich bis jetzt... Also hat mich bis jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt.
Haben die denn Reddit? Gucken wir mal, wie viel da los ist.
Oh, da können wir mal gucken. Da wird bestimmt geflamed.
Beautiful Linux Desktop. Wenn der genauso gut funktioniert wie der XFCE Desktop, dann mal außen vor.
Wish I had a Dollar for every art piece. Ja, da hat er recht.
Da hat er recht.
Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, man kann auf der China-Distro so lange rumhaken, wie man will.
Also Usability und so Gesamtkonzept hat mir deep in von allen Linux-Distros bisher am besten gefallen.
Trotz China Linux. Okay, wir starten einfach mal die Live-CD.
Dass der Chat sich nochmal mit dem scheiß Gnome lustig machen kann.
Wir müssen einfach warten, bis es gestartet ist.
Was hat das mit 1, 2 und 3 auf sich? Was? Wie? Wo? Hä?
Woop-Gnome und Woop-Ruby. Das kommt noch, das können wir noch machen.
Ah, jetzt tut sich was.
Okay, hier kann man schon mal auf den Desktop gar nicht klicken. Gibt keinen Desktop. Desktop ist overrated.
Display Settings funktioniert auch schon mal nicht. Settings geht auch nicht auf. Okay, excellent.
Aber Startmenü geht. Das ist Arch-based, ja. Tweaks.
Okay, das funktioniert jetzt wenigstens halbwegs. Warum die Settings nicht aufgehen, weiß ich nicht.
Merkwürdig. Also, noch mal so. Firefox, Browser, ich habe keinen Browser.
Zumindest nicht immer Live, zumindest nicht immer Live-CD. Aber einen VLC gibt es.
Kein Browser, aber hier ist er doch. Brave, alles klar.
Der Chat dreht voll am Rad, Alter.
Konnte man unter Gnome nicht Fenster resizen mit Alt und mittlerer Maustaste oder Alt-Rechtsklick oder so?
Es funktioniert deep in eigener Haus, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, deswegen sage ich ja immer dabei,
wenn man damit keine Probleme an der China-Distro zu verwenden.
Ach jetzt, jetzt geht es auf einmal. Eben ging es nicht. Okay, die Gnome-Variante, aber die Seams, ich weiß nicht.
Aber die Gnome-Variante scheint ein bisschen schlüssiger, besser in sich zu funktionieren.
Ja, da geht es resizen auch und sowas. Aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt müssen wir die Hacker-Variante installieren.
Alter, Chat, kriegt euch wieder ein, sonst müsst ihr 8 Stunden What's New in PHP 8 angucken.
So, also jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir damit klarkommen. Ach du Scheiße. Jaja, ja. Anyway, Reboot.
Power off. Monarch-S, aber richtig Monarch-S, wow.
Ah ja gut, ich habe ihm gerade die CD rausgerissen, das war keine allzu nette Geste von mir, das gebe ich zu. Restart.
CD, aber jetzt ist das CD nicht gemountet, auch gut. Haben wir das Richtige gemountet?
D, HL, ISO, CD, Start. Jetzt komme ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal klar, Chat.
Jetzt komme ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal klar, weil den Window-Manager habe ich schon nie verwendet.
Ich habe gesagt, ihr wisst, dass ich E3-Fan bin, aber den Teil des Window-Managers habe ich schon nie verwendet.
Wahrscheinlich weiß ich jetzt noch nicht mal, wie man ein Fenster aufmacht.
Oh, geht ja schon mal gut los. Mit einfach nichts. Oh doch. Guck mal, es gibt ein Fenster, das leckt.
Alter, das leckt. What the fuck. Massive-Lack.
Extreme-Lack.
Kein Hartveränderer. Okay, das sind unterschiedliche Desktops.
Okay, finde ich ganz nice. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was ist ein Run-Dialog? Ach, hier kommen Keybindings.
Super W ist ein Browser. Oh, was ist das?
Das ist ja mal hier.
Massive Graphics.
Das ist quasi der Task-Manager in ASCII oder so, fast in ASCII.
Alter, YouTube macht keine kack Pop-Ups, gehen wir nicht auf den Sack.
Oder ist das die Netzwerkbandbreite? Das könnte auch die Netzwerkbandbreite sein.
Welcher WM ist das? Das müsste jetzt Herbstluft-WM sein.
Ich glaube mal, dass HLWM und Herbstluft-WM das gleiche ist.
Ist das die Netzwerkbandbreite oder ist das die CPU-Auslastung?
Oh, die offizielle Seite von diesem Window-Manager sieht natürlich exquisite aus.
Nicht Herbstlust, Herbstluft.
Ah, yes, das ist eine gute Webseite, Leute. Endlich mal wieder wie 1995.
So müssen Webseiten aussehen, vor allem diese Schriftart.
Und diese Schriftgröße ist richtig 2020.
Ja, ja, chat, da geht mir auch einer ab, wenn ich die Webseite sehe.
Ah, yes. Okay, das ist die CPU-Auslastung hier gerade.
Okay, ja, gut, wie installiere ich das jetzt?
Terminal, super, Enter.
Okay, die Fonts fehlen, vielleicht sollte ich doch mal installieren.
Super E ist Visual Studio Code, standardmäßig drauf, okay.
Startet aber nicht. Super D ist was. Macht auch nichts, okay.
Und Terminal, super, Enter. Was ist denn das, Termite oder so? Ich weiß es gerade nicht.
Ist Brave eigentlich ein brauchbarer Browser? Ah, nee, Urksft ist es.
So.
Wie kriege ich den Installer jetzt wieder gestartet, nachdem ich den zugeklickt habe?
Gar nicht wahrscheinlich, da muss ich wahrscheinlich neu starten.
Gehe ich Reboot immer.
Das habe ich eine ganze Weile verwendet, früher Urksft wegen Unicode Support.
Aber das ist mittlerweile ziemlich ins Hintertreffen geraten.
Und fühlt sich komisch an, wenn man andere Terminals gewöhnt ist.
Ich glaube Urxvt verwendet die gleiche Font-Rendering-Geschichte wie Emacs.
Und deswegen fühlt sich auch Emacs merkwürdig an, was Sachen markieren angeht und sonst was.
Und ich glaube, die hatten bis vor kurzem auch keinen Emoji-Support.
Was für mich das Allerwichtigste ist, Emoji-Support im Terminal.
Oh, ich Kacknoob, ich habe das falsche gestartet.
Ich wollte ja von CD starten.
Xterm, oh hör mal auf, man kann es ja noch übertreiben.
Xterm hat aber, finde ich, noch so seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Xterm kann halt irgendwie jeden auch noch so abgetreten Oldschool-Scheiß.
Okay, Run Calamares, jawoll.
Runner die Calamares.
By the way, die Schrift ist deutlich schöner und lesbarer als in der XFCE-Variante.
Okay, American English, wir überspringen das jetzt einfach mal alles, weil wir können ja immer noch nachinstallieren.
Yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup.
German.
Und dann, no deadkeys, alles klar.
Partitions, erase all.
No swap, next.
Your full name, hatten wir noch schon, cute chat.
5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
Alles klar next install zack ok jetzt können wir uns wieder den das naruto cosplay angucken
Was passiert eigentlich wenn ich es jetzt doppelt starte kackt er dann ab
Ok das glaube ich keine gute idee zu partitionieren während er am start ist
Es gibt zwei bilder mehr war im pg nicht drinnen zwei bilder auf fiver beauftragt muss reichen
Ja da sieht man dass es nicht alles ist wenn der desktop auf den ersten blick beautiful aussieht weil was bedeuten das man hat ein
Ordentliches icon theme ausgewählt man hat sich ein ordentliches hintergrund bild rausgesucht und dann sieht es beautiful aus frage ist
Halt wie gut vorkonfiguriert und benutzt war das ganze ist
Und da sind zumindest die xf ce variante hat bei mir jetzt extrem gefällt
Ach die haben den recht mit nintendo noch einkalkuliert für das für das wie heißt dieses pokemon eigentlich auf
Auf deutsch ist das schicki oder so
Ne wie heißt das
Das schicki alter ich als pokemon du weißt wenigstens weiß dass das schicki ist
Alter ist aber massif
Big nur durch die ganzen durch die ganzen subs wusste ich das jetzt weil ansonsten habe ich von pokemon echt kein plan
Musst du nicht das us löschen nee ich habe ja gesagt er soll alles für mich löschen
Also die xf ce variante hat mich nicht überzeugt
eiswm habe ich früher sogar mal verwendet
Ob ihr das noch kennt das sieht ein bisschen aus wie windows 95 windows 95 aus eiswm
Ja das habe ich früher sogar mal verwendet eiswm
Ich meine es sieht halt auch wirklich aus wie früher
Ja das habe ich früher mal verwendet und zwar ich kann mich noch dran erinnern ich hatte mal
vor an das ist wirklich schon ganz ganz lange irgendwie fragt mich nicht
2003 oder 2 oder so da hatte ich noch einen ganz ganz alten pentium
2400 ausgebundelt und wollte da drauf linux drauf laufen lassen und da hatte ich auch irgendwas mit eiswm drauf
Da war kobold neu
Leute ich glaube dort wo kobold neu war das hat keiner von uns im chat erlebt
Kobold war neu zu 1900 fragt mich nicht 70 oder so
Also da da waren die richtigen boomer am start nicht die leute die man heute so
Lustigerweise als boomer bezeichnet kobold als die die mitbekommen haben wann kobold neu waren das waren die richtigen boomer
Fortran stream jetzt nächsten weihnachten leute nächsten weihnachten ich habe jetzt zeit ich kann mich jetzt mit allem rausreden nächsten weihnachten
Ja war kobold devops, ey über das video haben sich viele leute aufgeregt ja
Und haben gesagt wie kann ich es wagen
Zu behaupten die leute würden nur wegen dem geld wegen arbeiten gehen hat wirklich jemand geschrieben
Das ist bei it ja überhaupt nicht relevant ich weiß nicht wegen was ihr arbeiten geht aber ich würde mal behaupten
Die allermeisten wenn ihnen die firma nicht gerade gehört gehen wegen geld arbeiten
Ich weiß nicht was ihr arbeiten geht aber ich würde mal behaupten
Ich arbeite auch nur just for fun. Ja genau ich sage nicht dass es nur geld ist ja also nicht
100% nicht ausschließlich geld also sagen wir so so arbeits atmosphäre und und generell das umfeld ist schon nicht unwichtig
aber
Geld macht den größten teil des anreiz ist aus arbeit zu gehen ja
Okay restart
Fortam Street Park
Jetzt fangt nicht schon jetzt fangt nicht schon am 2 januar an mit was wir nächsten weihnachten für den stream machen müssen
So jetzt haben wir installt
Okay, also wie bedient man den kram jetzt wie es kaut super super und e drücken
Was aber nichts bringt was soll das muss doch in den startmenü haben also ich habe die menü in die menü
Variante also die menü steht auch sogar da super schifft weh
super schifft weh
Jetzt
excellent excellent
Da kann man schon mal gucken ok das ist aber das ist aber das ganz primitiv oldschool billig
Die menü a rofi haben sie auch am start ok super schiff de da ist schon mal
Ah ja damit komme ich schon besser zurecht
So ab ist sie klein aber immerhin
Und ich sterbe mir live und und stream
At block oh jetzt nicht hell to execute at block
Ok mit den key bindings komme ich noch nicht so ganz klar aber das liegt daran weil ich meine i3 key bindings
Gewöhnt bin super schifft de
Ok
Brave ist drauf ok
Schon gleich mit dark theme ok ok
Exzellent was ist die standard suchmaschine 0w
google
Jetzt gedacht die machen auch gleich irgendwie da da go oder sowas
Oh
So switch man desktops ich muss sagen also
Wenn man
Wenn man i3 gewöhnt ist ok wie viel wie verschiebt man
Ok das ist der factor oder weiß gar nicht wie das funktioniert wie man die fenster verschiebt
Ja gut da müsste man sich jetzt damit beschäftigen ab bat weil ich bin ja mit meinem i3 zufrieden so
Pascal stream ich kann nicht jede noch so alle programmierung machen ok aber desktop switchen ist schon mal nice
Das ist das ist exakt wie ich es auch bei mir unter i3 habe das ist cool jetzt müsste ich noch gerne wie ich fenster verschiebe ok
Fenster verschieben geht so alles klar
Frage ist so wie
Was windows schifft plus feil ja das ist das ist fenster verschieben in dem fall
Aber
Aber ich habe irgendwie kann ich die die größe von den fenstern verändern
Unten geht es nicht zack zack gibt es auch so was wie den resize mode
Ok ich habe keinen plan wie man fenster resized oder wie man fenster
in window mode
schaltet
Gibt es da konfig
Konfig
Alles klar
Windows R Windows R habe ich schon probiert das ist resize in i3 ja aber das geht hier nicht
Ok keine ahnung wie es geht
Wie resized man da
Resize
Button action
Ja das das probiere ich ja das geht ja nicht resizen resizen tut es ja nicht
Erlang stream es kommt als nächstes brainfuck stream
Mod control j
Du kannst im window mode nicht resizen ja aber
Ich muss doch sagen können dass das hier kleiner sein soll als das
Ok das schiebe ich jetzt nicht auf die größe
Konfig das schiebe ich da jetzt darauf dass ich keine ahnung wie es da ist
Alter ist das jetzt für irgendwelche das das sieht aus wie irgendein irgendwelche matte formeln oder so
Das ist ok das ist ok das ist ok
Das ist ok ex also das ist schon wirklich next level shit um einfach zu sagen wie man ein fenster resize
Mod schifft und dann fall nach rechter das ist verschieben
Ok ich bin da zu dumm für aber das liegt wie gesagt an mir weil ich das ding noch nicht verwendet hab
Ok aber aber man muss ja mal ihn so gut halten dass das prinzipiell jetzt anscheinend ganz gut funktioniert
Das ist der network manager
Das sieht sogar auch echt ganz gut aus
Das sieht sogar auch echt ganz hübsch gemacht aus also das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen zu verwenden außer vielleicht brave
Erst mal firefox installieren
Das passt top browser erst mal firefox installieren und dann chrome installieren
Gibt es ein linux auf dem alle games laufen nein
Games unter linux ist eh so ein ding wenn du glück hast funktioniert mittlerweile funktioniert ja einiges
Halbwegs
Aber wenn du problemlos spielen willst bleibt dir nichts anderes aus nichts anderes übrig außer windows zu verwenden
Zwei feile gleichzeitig drücken ne das geht auch nicht du musst windows verwenden ihr bleibt nichts anderes übrig
Also wenn du wirklich sicher gehen willst dass die spiele funktionieren auch im multiplayer
Und du auch neue sachen direkt bei release spielen kannst du dann einfach nur mit dem
clockwise Ideen auswählen im
Ark Esteban
und
Und du auch neue sachen direkt bei release spielen können möchtest, dann bleibt der nächste anderen super ausser Windows
Kontextmenütaste, ja die wirds sein, guck mal, guck mal was die Kontextmenütaste tolles fabriziert
Ja, also das ist ganz in ordnung vorkonfiguriert, das ist in ordnung
Was ist das?
Was
Deskrit ist das Discord
Ich weiß nicht was uns das hier oben sagen soll da bin ich zu small brain für
CPU Festplatte Kalender ok
Man kann ausschalten und kann Q-Chat rebooten ok
Gibt es nicht irgendeine Software die automatisch noch vor allem mit Windows öffnet wenn ich in den
Game auf Linux starte das kannst du mit sicherheit machen allerdings laufen games in der vm nicht ordentlich
Außer alte games sehr alte games
Ja ok das ist doch jetzt ganz nett was was war hier was war start menu super shift
Und d das kann man verwenden
Das kann man benutzen das finde ich in ordnung
Ist das ein bisschen doof ist dass ich nicht weiß wie man Fenster resized das wäre schon ganz nice zu wissen dass das dann nicht so aussieht
Ja das ganz nett das gefällt mir
Da wie gesagt das würde ich das würde ich verwenden ja das würde ich verwenden
Allerdings ist mir ganz ehrlich mein ordentlich konfiguriertes i3
Mit
Teil in window manager halt lieber kann man nicht gpu passt schon für games auf einer vm machen
Nee nicht wenn du unter windows bist
Ach so wenn du oder linux bist
Ja wenn du unter linux bist kann man das machen wobei das andere probleme mit sich bringt
Ja da musst du dir nämlich überlegen wie kriegst du beispielsweise die maus in die vm
Also wie willst du ne also brauchst du input in der vm
Für das für das game
Weil du hast ja dann direkt ein output auf dem monitor du hast ja dann keine vm mehr in dem fenster
Sondern du hast einen eigenen monitor dran
Wo dann die vm drauf kommt wenn du gpu passt du drauf machst dann muss da auch noch muss da auch noch eine maus und tastatur passt runen
Und dann wird es ein bisschen eng auf dem schreibtisch dann kannst du dir im endeffekt auch zwei rechner hinstelle
Vielleicht muss man eine vm programmeni auf sowas optimiert das dir das problem ist gar nicht so sehr
Dass man das dass man das machen müsste
Die sache ist die das ist nicht so ohne weil du müsstest ja dann
Eine vollständige grafikkarte emulieren
Die direkt x12 und valken kompatibel ist und das performant machen das kannst du knicken
Also die tun sich ja schon mit mit die x und und älteren open gl in vm wäre richtig schwer
Das programmiert das wird keiner programmieren ich ich habe auch so meine zweifel ob das überhaupt
Möglich ist dass das ordentlich funktioniert gerade
Weil direkt x12 und valken ja nun wirklich nix unkomplexes sind ja
Ne ne ne das wird nicht funktionieren
Wie gesagt du kannst gpu passt du machen
Aber damit kriegst du wieder ganz andere probleme und die sache ist halt die musst halt mal überlegen wenn du eine vm starten willst
Mit windows drauf um da drin dann zu spielen selbst wenn man mal von ausgehen würde
Das geht das heißt du brauchst nach wie vor windows
Was im umkehrschluss wieder heißt du kannst doch auch windows verwenden
Und darauf eine vm laufen lassen so wie ich es hier beispielsweise mache
Dann hast du nämlich alle vorteile von windows und so ziemlich alle vorteile von linux weil linux läuft in der vm absolut top
Du merkst also ich benutze tagtäglich auf der arbeit
Linux und ich merke zwischen der lade und der lade
Arbeit linux und ich merke zwischen der linux vm hier und meinem arbeits laptop kaum den unterschied
Das liegt aber auch daran weil unsere arbeits laptops
Jetzt nicht die allerschnellsten sind ja
Das kommt auch noch dabei genau um gpu passt zu zu machen brauchst du auch ein gescheites board
Die das da macht jeder hersteller so ein bisschen legt er die pci spezifikation und sachen so ein bisschen nach gut dünken aus
Und wenn du pech hast passt pass trußt du dann auf einmal drei pci gerät obwohl du eigentlich die grafikade durchreichen willst und so was
Und dual boot will man nicht machen
Dual boot hast du das problem dass du quasi laufen hin und her switchen muss zwischen verschiedenen betriebs das ist auch nervig also
Ich kann es euch empfehlen die beste variante ist installiert euch den windows
Und macht darauf vor immer workstation linux vm
Was ist denn das das ist ein aquarium bildschirmschoner, den ich als einfach nur mal angemacht habe just for fun
Es ist kein es ist kein ascii angel game oder so ich hole jetzt hier nicht den fisch grad raus mach keine achievements
achievements unlocked
Ja also das war aber noch die beste variante install wenn du wenn du wirklich spielen willst und da auch
fokus drauf liegt und du willst das multiplayer spieler
Problemlos funktionieren und das neue spiele bei release problemlos funktionieren installier windows und installiere die lungs in der vm
Aber guck mal und wenn mir eine ankommt mit dual boot
Und das ist die beste variante
Funktionen installier windows und installiere die lungs in der vm aber guck mal und wenn mir eine ankommt mit dual boot
So schnell wie ich hier zwischen meinem windows und meinem linux
Wechsel machst du mit dual boot nicht dazu kommt dass du die ganzen graben neu starten musst und das einfach nervig ist
Das wird das macht man nicht das denkt das hört sich der theorie gut an aber praktisch gesehen macht man es nicht
Dann musst du noch dein passport eingeben weil du voll verschlüsselt hast
Was also eine vm mit linux auf windows dann startet die form automatisch dass man immer direkt
Was warum warum
Also du kannst das sicherlich so einrichten dass die vm automatisch startet
dass die vm automatisch startet
Aber sag mal so die fünf sekunden
vor allem bei workstation aufzumachen
Hat man ja eigentlich
Wie sieht das bei vm mit multimonitor support support aus geht benutze ich aber nicht deswegen kann ich ja nicht so viel zu sagen
Genau wenn man windows selten braucht dann kann man das machen
Also mal angenommen ich würde zu 90 prozent oder linux arbeiten ab und zu müsste ich mal windows starten um irgendwie mal schnell mal schnell was zu machen
Dann würde ich das auch so machen mit dual boot aber aktuell
Benutze ich halt quasi
Genauso oft windows wie wie wie
Und da ist das nervt halt das schöne ist jetzt kann er im endeffekt jeder machen was über was er will ja ich sage euch nur wie es bei mir ist und so wie ich das mache
Und alles andere wird mir auf den nerven gehen
Mcmini exzellent ich habe mir auch vor ein paar jahren schon mal überlegt ob ich hier Mcmini holen soll
Was ist das darf man das aufmachen
Und dann kann ich das aufmachen
Und dann kann ich das aufmachen und dann kann ich das aufmachen
Und dann kann ich das aufmachen und dann kann ich das aufmachen und dann kann ich das aufmachen und dann kann ich das aufmachen und dann kann ich das auf AREA
Und dann kann ich das aufmachen und dann kann ich das aufника
Klar, meinste die finden das geil, guck mal die sind bei Twitch so schafft drauf aktuell
was Urheberrechtssachen angeht, die finden es bestimmt nicht toll wenn man irgendwelche
Serial Keys zeigt.
Ja aber guck mal, also hiermit kommt man echt ganz gut klar, das ist ja quasi so wie
ich mein Hilungszeug eingerichtet hab, wunderbar und ich denke man kommt auch hier mit Heftores
klar wenn man hier den Tilingbindermanager verwendet, wobei ich sagen muss die Xfce Variante
hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen und wie gesagt ich hab eher keinen Grund umzusteigen
weil mein Manjaro mit die 3 halt gut funktioniert.
Hab ich euch heute eigentlich schon mal meine Heizungsüberwachung gezeigt, wo man jetzt
erkennen kann, dass ich gerade Heißwassertemperatur habe, 55 Grad, voll das unding das Prime Video
unter Linux nur mit 480p funktioniert, ja also ich wusste gar nicht das Prime Video
nur mit 480p funktioniert aber das ist ein allgemeines Problem was du unter Linux hast
wenn es um Multimediasachen geht, vieles ist da ein bisschen hinten dran, guck mal was
das für ein ewig ewiger ewiges hin und her und riesen Akt immer noch ist, dass du
Grafikkarten-Decoder verwenden kannst, also Video-Decoder mit der Grafikkarte machen
kannst im Browser unter Linux, das funktioniert ja bis heute nicht richtig und dann nur in
einer ganz speziellen Kombination und dann auch nicht für alle Video-Codecs, also das
ist alles nicht so schön, ja Linux hat eindeutig seine Vorteile aber Umgang interop mit irgendwelchem
Johnszeug ist es nicht, ja, das mag ein DRM-Problem sein, das gehe ich sogar mal ganz stark
von aus, dass es ein DRM-Problem ist und dass die Hersteller einfach kein Interesse haben
da dran das ordentlich zu machen, nichtdestotrotz ist es halt für den User trotzdem scheiße
und die Hersteller haben halt da nicht viel Priorität drauf und das wird auch so sein,
ich meine guckt euch das mal an, guckt euch das mal an, die Desktop-Verbreitung, das meinte
ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht, by the way mir tun die Augen weh, ihr OS-Market-Share,
so guckt euch das mal an, was ist das obere, Android, das nächste Windows, da muss ich
gar nicht unten hingucken, guckt mal ob das stimmt, Android Windows, ja, in Deutschland
witzigerweise sieht es ein bisschen anders aus, können wir uns gleich angucken, danach
iOS, danach Mac und irgendwo hier unten da Krebs-Lilux rum, da muss man sich nicht fragen
warum die Hersteller jetzt wenig Priorität haben da was dran zu ändern, was was ein
File fail von Microsoft, wieso was ist das, so viel Open Source steckt in Windows, warum
ist das ein Fail von Microsoft, will das jetzt nicht alles lesen müssen, Linux Server mit
dabei, naja, nachdem das eine Auswertung über Browser ist, kannst du davon ausgehen, das
ist Desktop-Systeme, der UWP ist generell Fail und Microsoft hat mich auch echt enttäuscht,
ich hab mich ja so drauf gefreut, dass endlich WinUI 3 rauskommt und Microsoft hat jetzt
gesagt, nee Unpackaged App gibt's nicht, es gibt einfach keine Unpackaged Desktop Apps,
das ist das, was die Leute damit machen wollen, um den ganzen UWP Shit und Code Signing Zertifikate
loszuwerden, warum sieht das überhaupt so kacke aus hier, aber da hat's Microsoft
gesagt, nee in diesem Preview machen wir das nicht, obwohl sie das für Preview 3 angekündigt
haben, ich weiß nicht, wann das Ganze erscheint, hast du Bitcoin, nee, aber ich glaub da Keeper
XY hat Bitcoin, warst du nicht so Kryptowährung mäßig am Start oder bring ich das jetzt
durcheinander, also Market Share, hier Desktop, Linux, excellent, 1% jawoll, du hast dein Wallet
nicht mehr, sag bloß du warst bei, ich hoffe nicht, übrigens Leute, wenn ich mir diesen
Market Share so angucke von 1%, glaubt ihr auch, glaubt ihr auch, dass 2021 das Jahr
des Linux Desktops wird, so wie jedes Jahr, klar, achso 0,03 Bitcoin, ja ich mein, es
werden das mittlerweile, 40.000 mal 0,03, immerhin 1,2k, kann man aber verkraften, besser als
40k, nee ich kann jetzt den Namen nicht sagen, aber du weißt vielleicht wen ich mein, der
bei uns auf der Arbeit groß rumgeprotzt hat mit seinem Bitcoin-Wallet, der jetzt nicht
mal da ist, der hat es ja auch verkackt, der hat ja auch kein Wallet mehr gehabt, der hat
irgendwie 16 Bitcoin oder sowas, der hätte heute richtig massig Kohle, tja man sollte
auf sein Wallet aufpassen, ich mein überleg mal 16 Bitcoin, was sind das, 16 mal, Alter,
der ärgert sich ey, wie kann man sein Wallet einfach verlieren, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
der Typ, der war eh ein bisschen sehr überheblich und irgendwie hat er zusammen mit einem Kollege
was gemacht und er hat irgendwie gemeint und sein Kollege hat irgendwie das Wallet da gemacht
und keine Ahnung, vielleicht hat er auch einfach nur Mist erzählt, aber endgeblich hat er
ein Wallet gehabt mit 16 Bitcoins und das, keine Ahnung, hat er jetzt nicht mehr, kann
er nicht mehr drauf zukreifen oder sonst was, vielleicht hat er auch einfach nur Mist erzählt,
ich weiß es nicht.
Wobei ich mir das bei dem tatsächlich vorstellen kann, der hat bei jedem Hype-Scheiß mitgemacht
und der ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, also der war auf jeden Fall auch am Start,
wo man sich noch 16 Bitcoins meinen konnte, ist das der scheiß Gnome, nein das ist E3WM,
die Pizza die mit Bitcoin gekauft wurde, ja das stimmt, ich mein mir ist auch klar, dass
man das nicht so sehen darf, zum damaligen Zeitpunkt haben die die Pizza angeboten und
beide Seiten waren damit einverstanden, aber trotzdem wird es mich trotzdem ärgern, Pizza
oder 40.000 Euro oder was haben wir denn aktuell gerade, Bitcoin Kurs, ah ok, wie komme ich
noch 40.000, wir sind gerade bei 30.000 und Keeper XY freust du dich schon wieder auf
das Arbeiten nächste Woche, ich weiß nicht ob du Urlaub hattest, ich kann mich ja kaum
halten ne, oh alter guckt euch das mal an hier, hier haben sie das letzte Mal schon
rumgeflamet so nach dem Motto, oh nee, die Bitcoin plase und blau und sonst was und jetzt
guckt mal hier, BÄM ALTER BÄM, also wenn das mal wieder runter geht, ohne Scheiß dann
kaufe ich auch Bitcoin, easy, ich muss eh mal meine Kohle irgendwo hin, nicht alles Leute
garantiert nicht, ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwie, frag mich nicht 150k oder so in Bitcoin stecken
das mache ich nicht, aber so einfach weil es geht, wenn das wieder runter geht, all
in Krypto plase, nee sowas mache ich nicht, sowas mache ich nicht, man könnte sich auch
FIFA Packs kaufen, das ist auch eine wahre, das ist eine sehr gute Investition ja, einfach
FIFA Packs oder FIFA Coins über irgendeinen Keyshop, wie sieht es eigentlich mit Monero
gerade so aus, Monero ist der Kram den Cristiano Ronaldo was ich auf der Homepage gemeint hat
oder war das Esteril oder wie das andere heißt, nee ich glaube Monero hat er gemeint, wobei
man ja sagen muss das garantiert nicht Cristiano Ronaldo selbst Monero gemeint hat auf seiner
Webseite, sondern irgendwelche Big Brain Admins auf seiner Seite den JavaScript Miner installiert
haben, Leute ich hätte eigentlich die Idee, ich mache einfach irgendeine Seite wo die
Leute den ganzen Tag drauf gehen und da rum eideln und dann mache ich einen JavaScript
Miner drauf und dann promote ich das wie verrückt auf YouTube, ich meine guckt euch die ganzen
Scammer Shops an die CS Skins gesellt haben, mit so übelst shady practice dahinter, Syndicate
mit seinem Shop und alles mögliche, die haben auch übelst einen Crap gemacht und das auf
ihrem YouTube promoted, warum soll ich das nicht auch machen, das war kein Shop, das
war Gambling, er hat halt gefaked dass man da gewinnt, was halt auch schon echt fragwürdig
ist, da sieht ihr auch die Scheißen auf ihre Fans komplett, lohnt sich Mining noch, nee
ich habe ein Video gesehen von einem, das war eigentlich richtig cool, der hat, das gucken
wir jetzt nicht, ich zeige euch nochmal was ich meine, Bitcoin Mining Solar Power hatte
der, nee nee nee nee, das war irgendwie so ein alter Sack, ich finde es im Prinzip ist
auch egal, zumindest der hat einen riesen Solar Panel im Sommer im Garten stehen gehabt
und einen fetten Miner und eine Batterie und alles und der hat es einen Tag laufen gehabt
und hat glaube ich, ich habe vergessen wie die Cent Einheit von Bitcoin heißt, es gibt
noch etwas kleineres von Bitcoin, nicht Miyamoto aber so ähnlich, wie heißt es, Satoshi, Satoshi
genau und der hat irgendwie umgerechnet 0,005 Cent oder so gemeint am Tag mit seinem Solar
Panel Mining, also es war komplett unpraktikabel, nee nee nee, nicht das Semper Video, nee
nee nee, das meine ich nicht, nee nee, der hat nicht mit seinem normalen Rechner gemeint,
der hat sich irgend so einen gebrauchten Bitcoin Miner gekauft, so eine Kiste die im Endeffekt
nur aus Lüftern besteht, so und das hat sich halt überhaupt nicht gelohnt, übrigens soll
ich mal sagen, dass ich immer noch sehr begeistert davon bin, wie gut das mit der Heizung über
den Raspberry Pi, den wir letztens eingebaut haben, äh nicht installiert haben, den habe
ich jetzt hier im Betrieb und guckt mal, wie nice wir das im Stream eingerichtet haben,
ich habe hier komplette Übersicht über alle Sachen und ich kann jetzt auch nachgucken
und so weiß ich immer, dass ich beispielsweise, dass er nicht zu warm wird, was ja auch schon
mal wichtig ist, 45 Grad und ich sehe auch direkt, dass der RAM nicht vorläuft, der
Raspberry Pi ist mein Unify Controller und mein Webinterfaces für die Überwachungskameras,
allerdings Leute, by the way zum Thema Überwachungskameras, wir haben ja den Kram hier zusammen im Stream
mehr oder weniger zusammen, ich sage mal zusammen programmiert, ihr habt mir zugeguckt bei,
ich habe ein Problem, auf dem Raspberry Pi kackt das Ding einmal am Tag ab, mein Überwachungskamera
Software Ding, ich habe irgendwo einen Memory Leak drin und ich finde es nicht und ich vermute
mal, dass das irgendwo in diesem FFmpeg Scheiß ist und ich finde es nicht, irgendwo hier
bei FFmpeg ist das und ich habe keine Ahnung wo, ich sehe es, ah yes, mal kurz analysiert
schnell und das Problem ist, es ist kein normales Memory Leak, weil der Arbeitsspeicher wird
eigentlich gar nicht mehr, aber trotzdem meint.NET Out of Memory und die eigentliche Auslastung
geht nie über 170 MB RAM, aber trotzdem meint.NET Out of Memory, also vermute ich mal,
es liegt daran, weil irgendeine Collection zu groß wird oder sowas, ich weiß es ehrlich
gesagt nicht, das muss ich erst noch mal rauskriegen, hast du zufällig mal gezeigt, wie man Next
Cloud bei Docker Compose und Traffic korrekt installiert, oh da bin ich mir nicht so sicher,
ob wir Next Cloud installiert haben, haben wir Next Cloud über Docker Compose installiert,
wir haben auf jeden Fall Traffic mit Docker Compose mal installiert, aber ob wir Next
Cloud installiert haben, weiß ich nicht, aber du kannst nachgucken, guck mal wir haben doch
ein Archiv und im Archiv kannst du dann mal suchen, noch mal Docker, oh haben wir nicht,
tja wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie dieser Stream hieß, Traffic, war es schonmal nicht, ach
den habe ich gelöscht oder, kann es sein, dass es der Stream war, wo ich irgendwas geleakt
habe, den ich danach gelöscht habe, ich habe 2-3 Streams gelöscht, also das könnte tatsächlich
sein, ne, wie könnte dieser Stream, wie könnte dieser Stream, ne den lieg meine ich nicht
ClocksHD, ich meine nicht den Recording Ordner, wer war beim Recording Ordner dabei Chat,
wer hat sie überhaupt mitgekriegt, die könnten, okay meine Stream Benamungen sind ja oftmals
nicht sonderlich clever, das könnte durchaus sein, dass ich das einfach MonkaS genannt
habe oder so, in welchem Stream habe ich das gemacht, das habe ich irgendwann hier gemacht,
ich mag Emojis im Titel, wie man sieht, ach das war überhaupt nichts Schlimmes, ich wollte
mal nachgucken, Aufnahme von irgendeinem Gameplay und da bin ich in den Ordner gegangen, wo
Shadowplay die Sachen speichert und da war halt ein unglückliches Thumbnail drinne von
einer Aufnahme und da ist natürlich der Chat wieder komplett drauf angesprungen, ne, Reverse
Proxy, alter der Phipps, guck mal wie er das einfach rauskriegt, ja das, das könnte sein
hier, Reverse Proxy Linux Let's Encrypt einrichten, ja das ist es glaube ich, okay Stream vom
1.7.2020, guck mal hier der Chat kennt sich aus, 1.7.2020, was, aber downloaden darf ich
oder was, hä, was das für ein stumpf Sinn, what, aber wenn ich es doch runterladen kann,
warum kann ich es da nicht streamen, das ergibt doch absolut keinen Sinn, aber absolut null,
hä, kann mir das irgendjemand erklären, wo ist der Sinn, wo ist der Sinn davon, aber
guck mal also Bandbreiten mäßig kann es ja nicht dran liegen, ich darf es ja runterladen,
warum darf ich es da nicht streamen, hä, warum soll der Download, soll er nicht, letztlich
mein, okay, Streaming machst du HLS, das ist im Endeffekt eine Playliste mit kleinen, mit
kleinen Segmenten, das macht doch keinen großen Unterschied, wahrscheinlich um Filmstreaming
zu vermeiden, das könnte tatsächlich sein, Chainlaw sagt auch, das ist nice, das freut
mich immer, du hättest damals zur Amazon gehen müssen, als sie noch unlimited waren,
das freut mich immer, wenn ich sowas lese, Chainlaw schreibt, ich hab durch, wahrscheinlich
durch deines Streams, glaube ich sollte, hä, ich hab dadurch angefangen eine Programmiersprache
zu lernen, mich als IT-System-Elektroniker bei der Telekom zu bewerben und wurde angenommen,
danke für deinen tollen Streams, das ist super, dass das geklappt hat, das freut mich immer,
wenn ich sowas lese, exellent.
Hat er das jetzt downloadet, oder ist er noch dabei, er lädt noch, er lädt noch, ich meine,
das ist schon cool, wenn man mit 45 MB die Sekunde downloadet, das erfreut, wenn Vodafone
einfach das macht, wofür man Geld bezahlt, hol dir Hetzner Storage, warum, soll ich
was bezahlen, wenn ichs kostenlos krieg.
Wenn ich das wirklich jemand angucken will, kann er sich das auch runterladen, also so
viel ist ja nicht zu viel verlangt, bald Fitch, ach stimmt, der Sebaro hat ja Massive Hardware
aufgerüstet, ja, KeepAXY, du hast immer noch dein Zev Cluster daheim, wo wir gerade beim
Thema sind, wir hatten es doch letztens davon, die Leute, die übertreiben mit ihrem Home-Setup,
ich kenne da auch ein paar, aber du hast kein Zev mehr, mit was machst du jetzt, 120 TB
BTRFS oder was, was machst du, Cluster oder, was nicht MooseFS ist, so, also, hier, Archiv,
zack, aber der ist immer noch nicht fertig geladen, aber gleich, ah, Salonji BTRFS,
verstehe, BTRFS ist ja auch so ein Ding, jeder spricht es anders aus, ne, ich bin ja Fan
von BTRFS, es gibt Leute, die sagen ButterFS, dann gibt es Leute, die sagen BetterFS, gibt
es ja zig Aussprachen von, ich bin für BTRFS, so, also, VLC, haben wir es jetzt fertig
downloadet, jawoll, ok, also, schauen wir mal, was ich da gemacht habe im Stream, fängt ja
schon mal gut an, einfach ein perfekter Start vom Stream, ok, was habe ich da im Stream
gemacht, ah, DigitalOcean war das, ok, ok, aha, so, habe ich da Nextcloud installiert
irgendwo, Traffic, UMI habe ich gemacht, alles klar, UMI, ok, jetzt mache ich Traffic,
ApiTalken, was habe ich eigentlich gemacht, warum konnte ich das ApiTalken im Stream zeigen,
ich konnte das ApiTalken im Stream zeigen, weil ich, genau, die Absender IP eingestellt
habe, jaja, liegt, aber man konnte nichts machen, ich habe die Absender IP bei Cloudflare
eingestellt, vor allem I'm in, das Ding gibt es ja gar nicht mehr, ok, in Gitfronten habe
ich aufgesetzt noch, hatte ich da Nextcloud dabei, Watchtower zum Updaten von Containern,
ok, nee, ich glaube, Nextcloud haben wir nicht gemacht, übrigens noch, das müssen wir jetzt,
das muss jetzt sein, Leute, habe ich Lolcat installiert, wie, habe ich nicht, oder habe
ich doch, nee, umgedreht, ah, yes, exellent, so ist das noch viel besser, oder, das gibt
eben noch mal so den besonderen, den besonderen Kick, dem Aquarium, ja, ja, das ist ja der
Sinn von so einem Reverseproxy, also, na gut, der Sinn von einem Reverseproxy ist es ja
prinzipiell, ist es nicht, aber es bietet sich an, wenn man quasi eh schon eine zentrale
Stelle hat, worüber alle, also, die am Anfang, am Eingang steht, dass man darauf auch das
Zertifikatshandling für mehrere Dienste macht, ja, ja, das bietet sich an, was, C, Matrix,
ok, noch, oh, noch besser, noch besser, Leute, ok, jetzt fangen wir mal die Bitrate wieder
ab, oh, Leute, ich habe es kaputt gemacht, nee, jetzt, ok, jetzt ist die Bitrate im Arsch,
jetzt ist die, jetzt ist die, jetzt ist die Bitrate, jetzt ist RIP, ok, das aller, das
wichtigste hätten wir auch schon mal geklärt, oh, ha, mein Twitch ist gerade abgeschissen,
Leute, lull, hat es einfach neu gestartet, mein Browser, mein Browser Fenster mit Twitch,
hat es einfach neu gestartet gerade, jetzt lädt er aber mir den, sag mal, ist Twitch
gerade wieder voll am abkacken, kann das sein, nee, nee, nur mein Browser spinnt rum, Verbindung
zum Chat nicht möglich, Chat, Chat, geht es bei euch noch, könnt ihr noch chatten,
Bosschamp, ich glaube, der Twitch-Chat ist kaputt, oder der Chat ist kaputt,
wo habe ich schon mein Handy, jetzt muss ich mal vom Handy ausprobieren, ob es da geht,
also dass jetzt gar keiner was schreibt, als so diszipliniert, schätze ich den Twitch-Chat
nicht ein, oh ja, Twitch ist gerade am rumspacken, ich sehe es gerade in meiner Mobile-App, Alter,
das ist ja komplett im Arsch, Monka, das ist komplett RIP, das ist komplett RIP Twitch,
es geht gar nichts gerade, ja Chat, ist jetzt schwierig, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ihr sagt,
aber zumindest der Stream an sich scheint noch zu funktionieren, da bin ich ja schon
mal froh, dass der Stream an sich funktioniert, sehr gut, ja Chat, eigentlich bin ich ja durch
mit dem, was ich machen wollte, ist da Frazier am Start, ai frisi, nope, was, nee Twitch,
ist komplett hinüber jetzt, press F, wobei wir können kein F pressen für Twitch, weil
ihr könnt ja nichts machen im Chat, nur gut, ich glaube, ich glaube, Leute, ich glaube,
ich gehe jetzt einfach off, diese komische Distro habe ich jetzt ausprobiert, die hat
mich zumindest in XFCE überhaupt nicht überzeugt, andere, ja, kann man benutzen, wobei ich ja,
ehrlich gesagt, ich bin ja happy mit meinem E3 Manjaro-Konstrukt, ich sollte das vielleicht
mal löschen, den Download hier, ich meine, ich brauche ja nicht, lolcat hat es ein bisschen
kaputt gemacht, wir löschen mal, ich meine, ich muss hier keine 8GB Stream rumliegen haben
einfach so, weil es funktioniert, so, letzter Versuch, geht der Chat wieder, ah, Leute, der
Chat geht wieder, angeblich, angeblich geht der Chat wieder, ich konnte gerade Test schreiben,
MonkaS, aber mein OBS, mein OBS lädt schon mal nicht, Chat, nee, ne, oh, jetzt ist komplett
vorbei, wir wissen ja, möglichst oft, möglichst häufiges Refreshen sorgt dafür, dass es schneller
wieder funktioniert, OBS, funktioniert, kann ich euch das aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, als
Anbieter von irgendwelchen Webdiensten mag man es eigentlich nicht, wenn die User wie
verrückt Refreshen, aber nachdem wir ja hier ganz normale User sind, machen wir es einfach
trotzdem, also in meinem anderen Browser Fenster bin ich connected zum Chat und das funktioniert,
aber ich sehe von euch nichts und ich sehe von mir auch nichts, im anderen Fenster jetzt,
also scheint es so halb zu gehen, oder auch gar nicht, was macht denn das Ganze unter
Linux, geht es unter Linux jetzt, ah ja, dann würde ich fast sagen, ich mache jetzt Schluss,
war schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid, leider nicht so erfolgreich, wie ich mir das vorgestellt
habe, weil die Distro gefällt mir nicht, auf, äh, ausgehen please, ausgehen please,
sehr gut, oh, letzter Test, Chat, Connecting to Chat, gibt kein Chat Connect, na gut, also,
dann sehen wir uns, machts gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, morgen früh, oder? Ja, morgen früh
gehts schon weiter, alles klar, bis denn, machts gut, see you.